안녕하십니까, 재미선 여러분. 행복한
투자 예정을 함께하는 체슬리 모닝
브리프 7월 7일 화요일 일부
시작하겠습니다.
어제 중국 시장 어떻게 마감됐는지
왕정부장님과 함께 알아보겠습니다.네
>> 어제는 테크주 하라하면서 상 지수
매너스 0.65%는 속보
하라했습니다. 평성 태그 지수는
플러스 0.94포 94% 올라고 정시
거대면 3층 1조 외양까지
내려왔습니다. 업종별 보시면 어제는
에너지 소비제 금융 등 업종이
강세되었고 반면 커뮤니케이션 IT
소재 업정이 액세되었습니다.
어 정의화가 마진 계산 그리고 컵에
배당도 기대으로 에너지 권용주 어제는
오라하고요. 어 배터너는 1.4%
올라고 신호펜는 2.6% 중국 신화는
3% 올라왔어요.
이분기 실적 호조 그리고 저가 매수
자금 요입으로 화주도 돈
선승했습니다. 문화 하한이플 2.7%
올라고 장용선은 4% 화분 과한은
6% 올라왔어요. 소비자 관련주
어제도 반등했습니다. 비조마대 1%
본주는 2.3% 올라왔어요. 어 저가
매수 자금 요입으로 해스케어 관련주
0일 강세 보였습니다. 평서 제한은
플러스 4등 3% 올라고 화동 제한은
+ 1등 3% 몰라왔어요. 이번기
실적 기대감 그리고 추가 해외 수주
화대 등 기대목으로 정력 계기
관련주도 올라왔습니다. 4원테크는
4% 길소 주시잖아요. 우리 많이
이해하는 주식. 어제는 6% 우라하고
역전 신거기로 했습니다. 유시 동료는
플러스 5% 나왔어요. 이번에는
반도시 확대기대으로 일부 관영주도
몰라습니다. 기는 플러스 1.2%
올라고 해광 정보는 4% SMS는 +
2.6% 전전 테크는 플러스 4.5%
올라왔습니다. 홍콩 관련주 어제는 좀
우라하고요. 어 홍콩 흥선테크 안에서
보면은 튼센트는 어제는 4.8%
반면했습니다. 어제 아침에도 한 명이
있는데
>> 아리바바는 플 2% 시험미는 플러스
1.4% 올라왔어요.
>> 반면은 그 PCB CC와 관련
주어세는 다 조정 받았습니다.
>> 승인테크는 -4% 동생 정밀는
3.6%는
정료는 3% 빠졌어요. 어 신념물
구체 금리 어제 염증 5bp
하라했습니다. 이념물 구체 금리
플러스 염증 4b 선생하고
외화 환율는 염증 2 3% 정도
잘되었습니다.음
>> 감사합니다. 어, 말씀 주시는 중에
제가 맨 위에 저희 매일 보여 드린이
표 보다 보니까 하나 여쭤봐야겠다
생각한게 어, 위에 오른쪽에 보면
CSI 300 업종별로
>> 네.
>> 하루, 5일, 3개월 뭐 이렇게 쭉
연초 이후 이렇게 보여 주시는데
보면은 어, IT가 연초 이후에 한
46% 상승했으니까 뭐 압도적이고.
>> 네. 그리고 밑에 내려와 보시면
커뮤니케이션이 또 48%
어이 커뮤니케이션에는 우리가 알 만한
종목들 뭐가 들어가 있을까요?
>> 어 중제 우창
>> 중제창네 광통신 관련주들이 다
들어갔습니다.
>> 그 왜 커뮤니케이션이지?
>> 뭐 업종 [웃음]
하간 그래요?네
>> 통신으로 아마 좀 그려 되니까
>> 통신이라
>> 그럼 이제 광의의 IT다 뭐 이렇게
이해할 수도 있겠어요.
>> 예. 그렇고 또 많이 하락한 업종
보면 부동산은 뭐 당연히 업항 안
좋고 금리 높고네.
>> 아니다. 중국은 부동산이
>> 아 중국은 금리가 떨어지는 추세죠.음
>> 맞습니다. 그냥 유지하고 있는
추세고요. 아니면 지금 구체 신면물는
계속 1.74% 정도 그 유지하고
있습니다.
>> 그래서 대주이 그렇게 높지 않아요.
>> 음. 그러면 이제 전반적으로
>> 어퍼에 대한 불안감이 있어요.
>> 음. 어, 부동산이라 하면 이게 어,
여러 가지 요소를 봐야겠지만
>> 어, 부동산 가격 아니면 어, 건설이
되는 어떤 건 뭐라고 뭐라? 예,
개발 규모 뭐 이런 것들 중에 뭐가
걱정이 되는 겁니까? 어 초분 가격
두 번째 개발입니다. 개발 업체들이
그 부채가 되게 높잖아요.
>> 매 판매 매출 이런 건데 나오지
못하면은 약간 내종 부채 보독은
디스크도 있지 있는데 이런 이유는
거의 다 완화되었어요. 해소되었어요.
왜냐면 구조는 거의 다 마무리되고
다만 지금 부동산 어퍼는 1선 도시만
구부되고 있어요. 2선 3상 4
도시는 아직도 시간을 없어요. 그래서
시간 아마 좀 필요하겠는데 주무
없습니다. 아마이 실조적으로 보면은
거의 적자 흑자 적자 흑학자 그
수준이 유지하고 있습니다.
>> 이게 착곡 물량이나 수주 규모가
늘어나야 어 건설 업체들은 좋을 것
같은데 그런 부분에 대해서 아직 네
>> 변곡점이 보이지 않는다.
>> 음.네 네, 맞아요. 아마 초기
>> 초기. 음,
>> 알겠습니다. 어떻게 되는지 계속해서
업종 보는 것도 오랜만에 좀 흥미가
있어서 여쭤봤습니다. 밑에 이슈
종목은 화봉화학. 네. 화보가 실적
나왔어요. 어제 주가 거의 5% 가이
올라왔습니다.이 화목화는 중국대 그
스판덱스
제조 회사였고요. MS는 20%부터
25% 정도 유지하고 있고 글로벌
그냥 MS 기준으로 2위입니다. 중국
시장은 1등입니다. 어 CR5는
70% 되고요. 1등 회사는 그
효성티 TNT입니다. 맞아요.
>> 효
>> 어 3반기 순위는 동의부터
112% 증가 예상입니다. 역사로
하면 2분기 수 있는 동일 대비
111% 이상 증가 예상입니다.
교육도 거의 50% 이상 증가하고
있고 컨센서 대비는 상호였습니다. 어
상호의 조합원인은 스파텍스는 가격
인상 그리고 공장 가류 상승 때문에
허실전을 달성했습니다. 시장
데이터하다면 이번에는 승찬은 거의
32만도 나오고요. 동일 대비도
고증이 5% 증가하고 반면 수요량은
또 거의 동일 대비 17.4% 4%
증가했습니다. 그래서이 가격은 계속
올라왔어요.
>> 2번기 동사 가격은당 7,원 정도
인상했습니다. 2번기 스프라이드
돈당는 1.3만 외형으로 동기 대비
28% 상승, 교육는 플러스 27%
정도 상승했습니다. 최근의 가격은 좀
빠졌어요. 그래서 3분기 스프라이더
추가 계산 가능성도 있고요. 7월
2일 계중으로 스프라이더는 이미
1.5만 외형으로 2분기 대비 12%
정도 화퇴했습니다. 역사상 취업
스프라이드 돈다는 6만원 정도
됐고요. 그래서이 보단 매우 낮은
수준이야. 지금 올라가서도 낮은
중입니다. 평균치 대충 1.7부터
2.5만 외양 때문에 그래서이
스프레드 가격 올라도 큰 부담이
없습니다. 그래서 충구 증고사 리포드
보면 글로벌 스펜덱스 가격 인상
그리고 스프레드 개선 등육으로 매수
의견을 유지했습니다. 원래 보다 내년
내년 순위는 각가 40억 50억
60억하로 추진되었고 지존 대비는
32% 30% 29.5% 5% 큰포로
사용을 했습니다. 어 뭐 타켓 TP는
제시하지 않고요. 만에이 회사 대충
20회 정도 받을 수 있어요. 어
그러면 올해 20회 PR 적용하면은
TP는 12도 나올 수 있고요. 어제
종가 대비 거의 45% 없애음
>> 감사합니다.요
써 주신 말씀 중에 제가 이해 못한
부분 몇 개만 좀 여쭤 볼게요. 우선
중국 최대 스판데스 제조사다 이렇게
되어 있고 어 마켓어는 20에서
25% 중국 내에서 20에서
25%음네
>> 맞습니다. 글로벌 10%네
>> 10%네
>> 그리고 여기 CR
>> 5
>> 그냥 그
1위 1위부터는 5회까지 합쳐서 시장
장률 70% 되고요. 아, 상위 다섯
개 업체가 전체 시장 한 70%
정도라고 얘기해 주셨어요.
>> 어, 중간중간에 이제 가격 상승 뭐
이런 얘기가 나오시 나오긴 하는데
>> 네.
>> 어, 저희가 보통 PQC 분석이라고
하는데 실적이 좋아지는음
>> 원인 요소로 PQC 어떻게 됩니까?
다 해당됩니다.
>> 다 전부 다
>> 왜냐면이
스판덱스는
어 1등 회사 구회사이고요. 3등
회사는 그 화해하고요.
화해는 그 회사로 파생되었어요.
>> 음
>> 그래서 그 그쪽은 큐고 정찰은
없어요.이 회자는 계속 정찰하고
있습니다.이 회사 그리고 효선 TNC
있는 저 회사는 정찰하고 있습니다.
지금 그래서 Q가 계속 올라가고
있고요.이 이 화해하대날 시장 전반
그 공급을량 줄였어요. 그래서 피도
올라가고 있어요. C는이 홀산 수직
해화가 되니까 시그도 개선되고
있습니다. 그래서 PQ 해가 됩니다.
>> 초기 그 플레이어가 업체가 10개
이상이었던 반도체 시장처럼 얼마나
싸게 공급하느냐 이게 지금 킥인
시장으로 봐도 됩니까?네 예,
맞습니다. 그렇게 보셔도 되고요.
왜냐면이 코로나
>> 후에는이 스펜덱스 회사이 호사 빼고는
대부분은 다 적자로 들어갔어요.
그래서 파산 이슈가 되게 많았어요.
최근 연년간은 그냥 뭐 공급 과연
공급 문제가 다 해소되고 이제는 그냥
다시 오라는 추정입니다. 이거
>> 말씀하시는 거 보면 상위 다섯 개
업제가 70%의 점유율은 갖고 있는데
>> 네. 어, 마치 휴대폰 산업에서
애플만 돈을 벌고 삼성전자가 하면
살짝 돈 벌고 3위 기업부터는 다
적하듯이 어, 다섯 개 업체들도
모두가 다 이익을 누리고 있는 건
아닌가 봐요.
>> 3위 업체가 구났다. 그리고 이런
말씀하시는 거 보니까.
>> 네. 대충 보면은 아마 1등 2등
회사만 돈 벌 수 있는 구조인 것
같습니다. 미에 뭐 내려가면은이
비용 구조가 되게 좋지 않아요. 자금
조달도 해야 하고 그리고 정할 때는
동의도 없으니까 되게 애매는 수준이고
그래서 1등 2등 회전 이렇게 뭐가
왜냐면 동인도 많잖아요. 동일 많고
비용을 잘 관리하니까플로
계속 들어올 수 있어요. 그래서 이런
회사는 아마 정할 수 있습니다.음
알겠습니다. 보고 트레이딩 정도 할
수 있는 종목이겠다라는 생각이 드는데
[콧방귀]
맞나요?
>> 아
>> 아니면 자기 투자
>> 어 이거 또 같은 질문 왜냐면 그
반도체 아니어서 약간 또
소외되었어요이 회사가.
>> 예 그런데 실적프니까 계속 우상형
상형 조정하는 회자는 나중에도 실적
보고 주가 우라 할 수 있다고
생각해요. 시간 좀 필요할 것
같습니다. 네. 아, 실적은 꾸준히
우상향하고 업항도 좋은데
>> IT 솔님 때문에 멀티플이 이렇게
>> 어, 원래 있어야 될 것보다 좀 낮게
위치되어 있는 회사다라는 생각을
소개시켜 주셨나 봅니다.
>> 네, 맞습니다.
>> 알겠습니다. 어저께 10센터
말씀드렸는데 오늘은 또 그 비슷한 그
결로 화봉 화학 말씀 주셨습니다.
관심 종목에 넣어 두도록 하겠습니다.
>> 전일 미국 시장 보겠습니다. 지수는
그냥 뭐 IT가 올랐나라고 생각됐는데
또 마이크론 주가 보니까 강보합 정도
어떻게 된 건지 우리 새로 대비하시는
장창민 프로와 함께 알아보겠습니다.
부탁드립니다. 전일 미국 시황
말씀드리겠습니다. 전일 미국 시장은
AI 트레이드가 다시 살아난
하루였다고 말씀드릴 수 있겠습니다.
주요 지수 먼저 보시면 SP 500이
0.86% 상승하였고요. 나스닥이
1%대 다우가 0.2% 2% 상승으로
가장 잘 올랐습니다. 일반 지수는
2%대로 가장 크게 상승하는 모습
보였습니다. 지수 상승을 이건
명확하게 기술조였는데요. 최근 반도체
쪽 차익 실현이 나오면서
>> 흔들렸던 시장이 오늘은 반도체 및
AI 인프라 쪽으로 자금이 되돌아왔고
반등했습니다.
다만 새로운 펀더멘탈 호재가 나와서
올라온 장애라기보다는 그동안
[목을 가다듬음] 눌렸던게 풀리는
안도성 반등에 가까웠다는 점을 먼저
말씀드리겠습니다.
우측 섹터 섹터 쪽 보시면 오늘 장성
쪽이 그대로 드러나는데요.
>> SP 500의 큰 비중을 차지하는
정부 기술, 자유소비제 커뮤니케이션
섹터가 오르면서 지수를 끌어올린 반면
방어 성격의 섹터들, 필수 소비제,
유틸리티, 부동산 섹터는 하락하는
모습 보였습니다. 돈이 안전한 쪽에서
빠져나와서 기술주로 이동한 리스크는
장이였다고 보시면 될 것 같습니다.
다음으로 금리하고 유가는 간략하게
짚고 넘어가겠습니다. 10년물 국채
금리는 4.47% 47%로 큰 변화가
없었고요. 유가는 WTI
기준.5달러로
소폭 하락하면서 여전히 10달러
아래에서 하방흐름 이어가고 있습니다.
왼쪽 피테크 및 주요 종목 보시면
애플 1.5% 상승하였고 테슬라
6.2% 상승하였고 로드컴 4.4%
상승하였고요. 전반적으로 상승하는
모습 보여주었고 마이크로소프트는
0.9% 9% 소폭 하여 있습니다.
그리고 반도체 쪽을 보시면 어 마이
마이크로는 2.5% 상승으로 좀
완만한 상승 보였는데요. AMD가
7.8% 8% 상승, TSMC가
4.9% 상승으로네 반독체 쪽도
전반적으로 상승하는 모습
보여주었습니다.
>> 다음으로 주목할 만한 개별 종목
말씀드리겠습니다. 먼저 테슬라가 6%
넘게 올랐는데요. 지난주에 2분기
인도량을 발표했는데 48만 대를
넘기면서 시장 예상을 7만대 이상 못
돌았습니다. 발표 당일에는 오히려
밸루에이션 부담으로 주가가 빠졌었는데
오늘은 로보택시 서비스를까지
확장한다는 소식이 나오고
애널리스트들이 인도량과 자율주행
진척을 근거로 목표가를 올리면서
반등했습니다.
테슬라는 전기차도 중요하지만 자율
주행하고 로봇 AI 네러티브로
거래되는 모습이 있어서 오늘 상승도
그 네러티브가 다시 살아난 걸로
보시면 될 것 같습니다. 그리고
여기서 같이 하나 같이 보셔야 할
종목으로 전기차 기업인 루시드가
10% 넘게 올랐다는 점입니다. 기존
하락하는 모습을 보여주다가 오늘
반등한 이유는 자율주행 로보택시
네러티브가 다시 부각된 영향을
보입니다. 루시드는 우하고 누로가
추진하는 로보택시 프로그램에 그래비티
SUV를 독점 공급하는
파트너사이고요.
2027년 성용 배치를 앞두고 이미
검증용 차량을 생산하고 있는
기업입니다.
다음으로 AMD 말씀드리겠습니다.
오늘 8% 가까이 급등하였는데 오늘
상승의 직접적인 트리거는 골드만
싹스가 목표 주가를 450달러에서
640달러로 대폭 상향한 겁니다.
여기에 AMD가 이번 달에 어드밴싱
AI라는 자체 AI 이벤트를 앞두고
있는데 여기서 M비디아에 맞서는 신역
렉 시스템하고 신규 하이퍼스켈러
고객을 발표할 거라는 기대감이 좀
존재합니다.
>> 음.
그리고 오늘 더 주목할 뉴스가
있었는데 방금 말씀드린 자율주행
얘기하고 연결됩니다. 일본의 완전
자율주행 스타트업 튜닝이 자금을
조달하면서 AMD의 벤처 부문인
AMD 벤처스를 신규 투자자로 넣었고
동시에 지금까지 거의 M비디아 침만
쓰던 AI 학습 물량의 약 10%를
AMD 집주로 돌리기 시작했습니다.
어,이 부분이 왜 의미가 있냐면
앞에서 테슬라 루시드가 자율주행이라는
응용적 수혜를 받고 있었다면 AMD는
그 자율주행 회사들이 AI를 학습시킬
때 쓰는 연산칩 그 밑단을 파고된
모습으로 보입니다. 자동차 AI 학습
시정은 그동안 엔비디아가 거의
독점하는 모습을 보였는데 거기에
AMD가 엔비디아 대안으로 채택되기
시작했다는 신호라고 볼 수 있을 것
같습니다.
그리고 다음으로 말씀드릴 기업은
아리스탄 네트스인데 이번 오늘 오늘
장으로 8% 넘게 올랐습니다.이
회사는 AI 데이터 센터 안에서
GPU들 연결하는 고속 네트워크
스위치를 만든 기업입니다. 예 하면
보통 엔비디아 같은 칩을 위주로
생각하시기 마련인데 그 칩들을
연결하는 네트워크 장비 쪽도 같이
수해를 볼 수 있다는 점 예시로
드리고자 기업 말씀드렸습니다.
마지막으로 브로드컴 4% 넘게
올랐는데요. 오늘 이게 가장 주목할
이슈였다고 판단됩니다. 로드컴하고
애플이 커스텀칩 공급 파트너십을
2031년까지 연장했다는 걸 오늘
SEC 공시로 발표했습니다.
브로드컴은 원래 아이폰에 들어가는
RF과 와이파이 블루투스 연결집을
오랫동안 공급해웠고 애플의 핵심
협력사입니다.
>> 이번에 여러 세대 애플 제품에 들어갈
커스텀 ASIC 실리콘을 개발
공급하는 단연 계약을 새로
매렸거든요. 이게 왜 중요하냐면
애플은 그동안 M시리즈 10이나 자체
모뎀처럼 반도체를 계속 내제야 하는
모습을 보여줬습니다. 그래서 시장에는
애플이 결국 브로드컵 물량도 자체
칩으로 대체하는 것이
>> 아니냐는 우려가 깔려 있었는데 이번
그 계약 연장을 통해서 그 내제
우려를 상당 부분 덜어줬다고
보입니다.
그래서 앞서 말씀드린 기업들의 상승을
관통하는 메시지는 오늘 시장이 AI
밸류체인의 여러 층이 그러니까
GPU, CPU, 커스텀 ASIC
같은 칩 그리고 그걸 연결하는
네트워크 장비 그리고 자율주행 로봇
같은 AI 응용까지 폭넓게 다시
사드렸다는 점입니다.
다음으로 매크로 지표도 하나 짚어
드리겠습니다. 어제 UR ISM
서비스업 지수가 발표됐는데요. 이거
이거 미국 서비스업 구매 담당자들
설문해서 만드는 지표인데 서비스업이
미국 경제 대부분을 차지하기 때문에
미국 경기의 채운기 같은 역할을
한다고 보시면 될 것 같습니다.
50을 넘으면 경기 확장 밑돌면
위축으로 읽을 수 있겠는데요. 어제
나온 6월 수치는 헤드라인 기준으로
54월 대비 좀 소폭 둔화된 모습을
보였지만 여전히 확장권이었고요. 시장
예상에도 부합했습니다. 24개월
연속으로 확장되는 모습 보이고
있고요. 참고로 말씀드리자면 앞서
이달 1월에 나온요 제조 PMI는
53.3으로 5월 대비해서 0.7%
7% 포인트 내려지면 이것도 6개월
연속 확장권이라고 볼 수 있겠습니다.
그래서 제조업하고 서비스업 둘 다
완만하게 둔화되고 있지만 확장을 계속
유지하는 그림이라고 보시면 될 것
같습니다. 자세한 사항은 2부에서
부사장님께서 말씀해 주실 것으로
저한테 말씀해 주셨습니다. [웃음]
>> 어 총 정리를 하자면 오늘 AI
밸류체인 전반으로 자금이 되돌아왔고
좀 반등하는 장이었다.
그리고 테슬라, AMD, 아리스타,
브로드컴처럼 칩 네트워크, AI
응용까지 통넓게 오른 장이었다고
말씀드릴 수 있겠습니다. 이상입니다.
>> 감사합니다. 기업들 소개시켜 주실 때
무엇, 무슨 일을 하는 기업인지
매출이 어디에서 나오는지도 꼼꼼히
짚어 주시니까 어, 저처럼 미국 기업
잘 모르는 사람들도 좀 더 이해가
쉽게 되는 거 같습니다. 오늘도
꼼꼼한 정리 감사드리고요. 말씀
주시는 동안 쭉 위에 보다 보니까
52주 신고가 종목에는 어 IT
외에도 헬스케어나 금융 이런 업종
내에서의 주요 종목들이 또 많이
보여요. 그래서 시장이 여전히 어
주요 종목들도 오르지만 좀 더
확산돼서 그 밖에 종목들도 많이
오르는구나 하는 생각이 들었고 아침에
헤드라인 뉴스 이렇게 쭉 보면서 오다
보니까 어 상대적으로 SMT
500이나 나스닥보단 덜 올랐지만
바오 지수가 계속해서 어 신고가를
갱신하고 있다는 뉴스들이 또
나오더라고요. 그래서 어 미국은
지수가 조정을 보이는게 아니라 다른
종목적으로 계속 전의가 되면서 시장은
계속 유지되고 지탱되는구나 하는
생각도 좀 해 봤습니다. 감사합니다.
이부에서 우리 창민 프로가 예구해
주신 대로 좀 더 자세한 내용을 최호
부사장과 함께 보도록 하고
가상자산으로 넘어가 보겠습니다.
준혁주입니다. 가상자산 어떻게
됐습니까?
>> 네. 가장 시장 말씀드리겠습니다.
어제 하루는 어 되게 호재와 악재가
강력하게 어 좀 명확하게 좀 작용하는
시장이었다라고 볼 수 있을 것
같은데요. 빨간색 박스를 제가 두 개
쳐 놨는데 가격 자체는
64,000불이지만 어제는 등락이
굉장히 컸습니다. 그래서 어 어제 한
8시 50분 한 9시 정도의 시간대가
첫 번째 박스인데요. 첫 번째
박스에서 그 마이크로스티지가 비트코인
3,600개 정도 매도했다라는 뉴스가
나오게 되면서 급락하는 모습
보여줬었습니다. 그래서 비트코인이 한
6만, 1천불, 어, 6만 천불
후반대 정도까지 하락하다가 다시 한번
상승하는 모습을 두 번째 박스에서
보여 드렸는데요.이 두 번째 박스는
어제 그 NYS 뉴욕 증권 거래소
250주년 행사가 있었던 거
같습니다. 이게 어 백악간 그
진무실에서 이루어졌는데 거기서 이제
벨도 치고 어 다양한 인터뷰도 하고
거기 나와서 이제 장관들이는 한
마디씩 다 하는 자리이더라고요.
그래서 거기서 트럼프 대통령이 어
트럼프 계좌를 만들고 있죠. 트럼프
어카운트를 만들고 있는데 그 트럼프
어카운트에 어 비트코인 추가될 수도
있다. 그런 식의 뉘앙스를 풍겨
주면서 다시 한번 반등하는 모습을
보여줬었습니다. 그래서 어제는 악재를
원른 악재만 좀 더 민감하게 반 반응
반 반응 반등을 하고 호재에는 거의
반응하지 않는 모습들을 최근에
흐름으로 보여줬었는데 어 어제는
호재도 호재로서 받아들이는 모습이 좀
긍정적이었다라고 볼 수 있을 것
같고요. 마이크로스티지가 센티먼 어
이제 비트코인을 팔 수 있다라는
가능성을 암시하고 나서 그게
센티먼트로서 형성이 됐었는데 그
센티먼트가 센티먼트뿐만 아니라 실제로
매도를 했다. 이렇게 이렇게 빨리
바로 3,500개를 매도했다라는 것이
어 시장에 조금 안 좋은 분위기로
계속해서 확산이 될 수 있었는데
어제는 트럼프와 백악관이 좀 그런
거를 어 회복시켜 줬다라고 보시면 될
거 같습니다. 어 그래서 비트코인
장기 차트 보시면 어 200주
이평선에 안착을 해서 끝난 모습을
끝나려고 하는 모습 어 위에서 지금
거래되고 있는 걸 보실 수가 있고
있을 것 같고요. 어 그래서이
200주 이평선 위에서 넣다라고 하면
이런 부분들은 어 6만불을 하회했던
부분이 어 확실하게 어 저점이었다는
건 저희가 확인을 할 수가 있기
때문에 이선을 잘 지키는지만
확인하시면 될 거 같습니다. 어 제가
방금 말씀드린 것처럼 너무 뜬거없는
트럼프와 백악간 이렇게 써 놨는데요.
어제 갑자기 타이밍이 조금 절묘했던
거 같습니다. 그래서 트럼프가 가격에
하락하고 나서 갑자기 어 크립토는
너무 큰 시장이다. 크립토 나 어
좋아한다. 이런 식으로 갑자기 뉴스가
나와 버리니까 어 좀 어리둥절 했던
거 같습니다. 이게 어 갑자기
크립토에 투자하거나 이런 것들이
아닌데 그냥이 트럼프의 입에 어
비트코인 가격이 조금 좌우되는
날이었던 거 같고요. 오른쪽에는 오늘
새벽에 나온 뉴스인데요. 어
비트코인의 그 백악간 경제자문
위원하는데 거기 안에서도 그 가장
잘한 팀이 있습니다. 그 팀 쪽에서
나온 뉴스인 거 같은데 어 처음에
2025년에 비 그 트럼프가 행정
명령으로서 비트코인을 전략적으로
보유하는 거에 대한 행정 명령을 사인
그 사인을 했었는데 그거에 대한
일환으로 그거에 대한 지금 기초를
지금 아직도 다지고 있다. 그리고
구조적으로도 조금 확실하게 하려고
하고 있다라는 식으로 어 뉴스가
나오게 되면서 다시 한번 상승하면서
지금 비트코인 가격이 거의
65,000불 정도에 도달했다이
정도는 보시면 될 거 같습니다. 어,
비트 피 그레디 인덱스를 보시면 어,
공포 구간까지로 조금 올라온 모습
보실 수 있고요.이 숫자는 24
정도를 기록하고 있습니다. 스트레티지
업데이트를 드리면 될 거 같은데요.
그 스트레티지가 지난주 그리고 어,
지진난주 지진난주 이렇게 총 합쳐서
3,500개 정도의 비트코인을 시장에
매도를 했습니다. 어, 좀 그래도
긍정적이었던 부분은 지난주 지진난주에
흐름이 안 좋았지만 지난주에는
비트코인 가격의 흐름이 나쁘지 않았던
걸로 제가 어, 말씀드렸던 걸
기억하거든요. 그래서 시장에서 흡수할
수 있는 능력이 어느 정도 생겼다.
어가 저 제가 봤을 때 좀 긍정적인
부분이라고 생각합니다. 그래서 어
사람들이 스트레티지의 이슈가 이미
선반영되었다, 프라이싱 되었다라고
언급하는 부분들이 굉장히 많았었는데
어 그런 부분들을 어느 정도 인정할
수 있는 어제 그리고 지난주 흐름이
아니었나는 생각을 어 개인적으로
했습니다. 그래서 어 스트레티지는
지금 이제 현금을 한 2.3빌리 정도
벌써 어
보유를 하고 있고요. 2분기에 나올
배당이나이자 관련된 비용들 이것들을
지출하겠다라고 하다 보니까 어
시장에서는 아 이제 주주들을 좀
챙기려고 하는구나 연구 우선주들을 좀
챙기려고 하는구나 이런 흐름으로
이해할 수 있지만 어 비트코인이 최대
수요자였던 그 스트레티지가 이제 파는
걸로 어 스탠스를 어 전환하였다는
거는 분명히 센티먼트에도 악화가 됐고
실제 실행했다는 것을 저희가 어제
확인할 수가 있었습니다. 어 주요
쪽은 보시면 어 가장 간단한 이슈를
하나 가져왔습니다. 어, 가장 주식
같은 주식 시큐리타이드가 상장했다라고
이렇게 써 놨는데요. 7월 2일 날
상장한 기업이긴 합니다. 어, 지난주
목요일 날 뉴욕증권 거래서의
SEZ라는
티커로 어, 시큐리타이즈가 상장을
했는데 이게 원래 스펙이었습니다.
스펙을 역합병해 가지고 상장을 한
우회 상장을 한 케이스인데요.
시큐리타이즈는 어, 주식을 토크화하는
토큰하는 비즈니스를 하고 있는
회사입니다. 그래서 하면 SEC가
어떤 건 되고 어떤 건 토크나가 안
된다. 어떤 건덕하로 인정이 안
된다라는 걸 한번 말씀을 드린 적이
있는데 다시 한번 상의시켜 드리면
실제 그 주주 명비 올라가는 형식만
지금 어 SC가 정식적으로 인정을 해
주고 있는 상태입니다. 어 그
가이드라인을 잘 따르고 있는게
시큐리타이즈이거든요. 그래서
시큐리타이즈는 좀 재밌었던 일화가 어
자신들이 어 시장이 상장되는 그 날에
어 시큐리타이즈 토큰 주식을 어 그
발행을 해 가지고 시장에 실제로 어
사람들 참여할 수 있게 실제로 발행을
했습니다. 그런 부분들이 아 토크나
주식하는 회사다 어 싶은 것을 저희가
확실하게 알 수 있게 어 그런
비즈니스를 하고 있는 회사이고
유일하게 발행사 보증 모델을 지금 어
잘 추진해서 가고 있는 회사가
시큐리타이스다라고 이해하시면 될 거
같고요. 그래서 시큐리타이스 토크
주식을 봐야 될 때 어떤 회사를 봐야
되느냐 했을 때는 시큐리타이즈가 가장
선봉장이 있다라고 말씀을 드릴 수가
있을 것 같습니다. 가이드라인에도
가장 앞서고 있고요. 그 규모
시큐리타이즈가 어 많이 앞서고 있는
상황이기 때문에 어 시큐리타이즈라는
회사를 한번 어 주목해서 보시면 될
거 같고요. 이게 뭐이 회사를
추천한다라기보다는 장기적인 시계월에서
시큐리타이즈가 현재 어 잔기
레이스에서 가장 앞서 있는 것은
사실이기 때문에 그런 차원에서 한번
말씀드렸습니다. 이상입니다.
시큐리타이즈라고 하는 회사 이름이죠.
회사는 회사
>> 무서 무슨무슨 자산을 토크나하고
있습니까? 어, 현재 주식을
>> 가장 우선적으로 하고 있는데 뭐
토크나라고 한 자산이니까 이거는 뭐
금도 될 수 있는데 금 같은 경우에는
STO 방식이라든지 이런 식으로 해서
실물 그 자산들을 직접 갖고 있어야지
그걸 할 수가 있거든요. 주식 같은
경우에는 회사에 컨택해서 그 발행사가
보증하는지 이거를 파악해서 주주명에
넣으면 되는 거기 때문에 제가 볼 때
우선 시큐리타이즈는 어 주식 주식
회사들 그니까 증권을 위주로 먼저
접근을 하고 있다라고 보여지고
있고요. 어 따로 이제 다른 자산들은
이제 얼마든지 더 확장할 수 있는
기회가 많기 때문에 우선
시큐리타이즈는 증권을 우선적으로 많이
하고 있다가 제가 확인한
결과였습니다. 주식 회사의 증권을
그러면 토크화 된다는 말은 저 너무
기초적인 질문이라 창피하지만 토크화
된다는 거는 어 소액 투자가
가능하다라는 개념으로 전 알고 있는데
그밖에 또 다른 장점도
>> 있습니다네. 어이 발행사 보증 모델이
SEC에서 유일하게 인정해 주는
이유가 있는데요. 어 발행사 보증
모델만 주주 명부의 실자로
올라가고요. 주주가 누릴 수 있는
가치들을 그 권리들을 다 누릴 수
있는게 발행사 보정 모델입니다.
그래서 실제로 시큐리타이즈 특권
지식을 샀다라고 하면 시큐리타이즈
주주가 되는 겁니다. 토에서
거의 토스증권에서 실제로 저희가
소수점 매매증에서 소수 매매 이런 걸
많이 하이 근데 그거와 이건 좀 다른
방식이긴 하 실제로 쪼개진 거고
쪼개진 것처럼 보이게 하는 거기도
있을 뻔이고 하지만 실제로 쪼개졌어도
어 그거를 실제 주주가 누릴 수 있는
뭐 배당이라든가 의결권이라든가 그 관
관련 관련된 권리들을 다 누릴 수
있는게 어 지금 스피사이즈가 하는
모델이다라고 보시면 됩니다.
>> 네. 어떤 방식으로 그렇게 주주들이
어 갖게 되는 권리들을 소액으로 나눠
주는지까지는 궁금한데 차후에 또
물어보도록 하겠습니다. 감사합니다.
오늘은 새로운 기업 시큐리타이즈에
대해서도 알아봤습니다. 예부 여기에서
조금 이르게 마칠까 합니다. 일부
함께 해 주신 채무탄 여러분
감사드리고요. 이부에서 조금 더
자세한 내용으로 뵙도록 하겠습니다.
일부 함께 해 주신 여러분
감사드립니다. 입니다.
[음악]
เฮ
안녕하세요. 행복한 투자의 여정을
체슬리 투자점과 함께 체슬리 모닝
브리프 오늘 7월 7일
어 화요일 수요일
>> 화요일입니다.
>> 화요일입니까? 네.화 순서 2부 순서
시작하도록 하겠습니다.
아 귀가 아침에
상 밖으로 들려는 빗소리도 참 시원한
느낌도 들고
비가 내려주니까 아주 좋습니다.
네. 전 세계가 물부족 현상을 겪고
있는데
이렇게 장마철이 조금 늦게 오긴
했었지만 때가 되면 이렇게 비가
와주고 해서
축복받은 나라 생각이 듭니다. 자,
어제 미국 시장에서
어 반도체가 처음에는 아주 강하게 좀
올라가는 모습이 나왔는데
>> 예.
>> 예. 조금
>> 상승을 좀 했습니다.
>> 예. 상봉 좀 반했고요.
반면에 어 또 테크 주식도 좀 강한
모습을 보였고 아까 청민 프로가
얘기해 줬듯이
약간
필수 소비제 방어 섹터에서 약간 이제
공격적으로 테크 쪽이나 커뮤니케이션
쪽으로 예 자금이 좀 옮겨가는듯한
이제 다시 7월장은 좀 공격 앞으로
해도 되나 뭐 약간 요런 느낌으로
미국 시장 움직이는 느낌이었고
국채 10년물도
다행히 소폭 하락을 했습니다.
>> 예.
>> 유가도 68.6불.
전체적인 시장 분위기는 어 나쁘지는
않았다가 MSCI 이머이 2.2
그리고 사우스 코리아 ETF는
5.94%
>> 그렇게 상승을 했습니다.
>> 자 3년 실적이 나온 거 같다.
그죠? 예.
>> 네.
>> 89조원 정도 지금 나와서 컨텐츠
대입 초복하 상회하였습니다.
>> 컨셉이 한 86에서 한 88
>> 네. 네. 86조 정도.
>> 86조였고
그래도 시장에서는 뭐 99조까지도
얘기는 나왔었잖아요.
>> 예. 예. 나왔고요. 그 마지막
처음에 이제 메리츠에서 이제 한
60조 금방에 시점 전망을 해 주셔서
가장 정확하게 마치
>> 아 메리체에서는 90조 음
>> 얘기를 했고
>> 여기게 이번에 노사 합의를 한 그
선거끝까지 다 이제 반영한 거잖아요.
>> 예. 대략 한 20조원 정도 반영했고
3분기 4분기는 10조씩 반영할
예정입니다.
>> 어
>> 20조 반영을 했고
>> 3, 4분기는 왜 줄어요? 아
2분기에 1분기 끝까지 한 번에
반영했어.
>> 아 1분기 끝까지.
>> 예예. 연간 전체로 반영할서.
>> 그 전체적으로 한 40조 정도.네
>> 맞습니다.
성과 빼면 꽤 잘 나온 거다. 그죠?
>> 예. 한 이제 올해 실 2분기
실적으로 100조 체력은 이제
됐다고.
>> 그렇네. 맞습니다. 예.
시장에서 기대했던 그동안에서 주가
상승 스토리에 걸맞는 실적은 나온
거다. 그죠?
>> 네.
>> 자, 시장의 관전 포인트로
>> 예.
뭐 제가 고민하고 있는 것이기도 하고
또 하반기에 어떤 포트를 가져가야
될지에 대한 어 고민이기도 합니다.
일단
그 실적은 뭐 물론이고 금리 수준이
지금 높기 때문에 그 금리 수준을 좀
떨어뜨릴 만한 요인이 있는지 아니면
어 계속해서 어 높은 레벨을 유지할
것인지에 대한 어 포인트로 유가하고
고용하고 뭐 소비 투자 물가 뭐 이런
뻔한 것들인데 어쨌든 이런 부분들을
조금 디테일하게 어 점검을 해야겠다는
생각을 하고 있고요. 아 포트폴리오
전략 쪽에서는
지금 JP 모건하고 어 모건 스탠님
또 다른 뭐 하우스들도 탑다운으로
보는 그런 관점에서는 어 다른 시각을
가지고 있는게 어 당연할 것
같은데요. 일단 JP모건 같은 경우는
어 반도체하고 하이퍼스케일러 AIP주
순호로 어 선호를 하고 있는데 어
반도체에 대해서는 최근 약세가 어
매수 기회라고 얘기를 하고 있고요.
M7은 실적하고 밸루에이션 순풍은
있지만 수익화 우려로 어 디레이팅이
지속될 것으로 예상된다라고 얘기를
하고 있습니다. 그리고 어 최근에 그
소프트웨어 같은 AI 피해주에
대해서는 과매도시 어 기술적 반등은
가능하다라고 하면서 어 전반적으로
이제 선호도 자체는 좀 차이간 차이는
있지만 어 그래도 어 최근에 이제
매크로 어 환경 발 환경에 어
기반해서
어느 정도 그 가능성은 어 전부 다
열어 놓는 어 그런 모습이고요.
모은 스탠리는 어 금리 부담이 좀
줄어들면서 M7 등으로의 순환매
국면이
아 진입될 것이다. 요런 식으로
얘기하고 있는데 아 두우스의 가장 큰
차이점은 반도체인데요. 어 JP모건은
현재 어 반도체 약세를 매수 기회로
보는 반면에 모건 스테니는 어 너무
그 뭐 과열이다. 좀 급등했다.
그리고 어 좋은 것들은 대체로 다
반영했기 때문에 어 반도체는 좀 쉬고
M7 등 다른 섹터로의 순환매 국면
또는 확정 국면이 이루어질 것이다라고
얘기를 하고 있습니다. 그래서 시장은
뭐이 중간 어느
시속 게임 뭐 줄다리기를 할 걸로
예상이 되는데 뭐니 뭐니해도 뭐 좋은
싼 그리고 적절한 어 종목들을
적절한 그 비중으로 가져가는게 좋은데
어쨌든 좀 그 2분 하반기에는 좀
이런 부분들에 좀 어 유념을 해서 어
포트폴리오를 구성을 해야 될 것
같습니다. 이게 쉬운 얘기는 아닌데
어쨌든
매크로 환경 관련해서는
어 계속해서 봐야 될 거 같고
그중에서도
실적 대비 조금 저렴한 종목들로 어
기회가 있지 않을까라고 생각을
합니다. 6월 ISM 서비스 PMI가
나왔는데 54가 나왔습니다. 컨센이
54였고 전 54.5에서 0.5%
0.5% 5% 포인트 정도 어
낮아졌는데음
증가한 정 항목으로 고용이 좀 증가를
했습니다. 그리고 수장고도 좀 증가를
했고요. 고용 쪽에서
어 증가 요인을 어 기술해 놨는데
전부 다 뭐 고용이 증가한 건 아니고
선별적으로 나타났고 어 월드컵 관련
고용이 고용 지수 상승에 기여했을
가능성이 높다고 이렇게 ISM에서는
판단을 하고 있고요. 감수 항목에서는
어 기업 활동하고 신규 주문, 공급자
배송 이런 것들이 감소했고
소폭 조금씩 감소를 했다고 보시면 될
거 같고 어 물가 쪽에서 어
동그라미를 쳐 놨는데 어 5월이
71.3에서 67.7로 7로 어 크게
감소를 했습니다. 그래서 이전에 어
제조업 쪽에서도 어 물가 부분을 좀
유심히 봤었는데 그때도 어 5월보다
6월에 좀 감소를 했고 서비스업
쪽에서도 어 감소를 했기 때문에 물가
관련된 어 이슈들을 어 좀 뒤에서 좀
살펴볼 거고요. 일단 어 설모 응답
쪽 보시면은
약간 비용이나 가격 상승 그리고 병목
요런 부분들에 대해서 언급해 놓은
것들이 눈에 띄었고요. 어 숙방 및
시급료 서비스 관련돼서 비용 증가로
인해서 공급 업체들은 가격 인상을
소비자에게 전가하기 위해서 노력하고
있다라고 얘기를 하고 있고 농림
수산업 쪽에서는 일안 전쟁으로 인한
비용 증가와 감뭄으로 인한 사료 작물
손실로 인한 재정적 부담은 농업
부문의 지출 감소로 이어지고 있다라고
했습니다. 건설 건설 쪽에서는 향후
프로젝트 수주 물량이 풍부하고 자재
가격이 상승하고 있으며 데이터 센터
배관 관련 납품에 아 부품에 납기가
길어지고 있다고 하면서 이쪽에 조금
병목이 있는 거 같고요.
금융 보험 쪽에선 어 메모리 공급
부족 우려가 커지고 있으며이는 제품
강용성에 영향을 주고 있고 회사의
구매 결정에 영향을 주고 있다라고
했습니다. 들 좀 비싸 가지고 구매
결정하는데 좀 어려움을 겪고 있다.
이렇게 이해하면 될 거 같고 보건 및
사회복지 쪽에서는 중동 분쟁이
지속되면서 원가 상승 가능성이
제기되고 있고 아직 현실화되지
않았지만 여전히 우려 사항이라고
얘기를 했습니다. 어 전문과학 및
기술 서비스에서
인프라 프로젝트에 대한 수요는 여전히
강세를 보이고 있다라고 언급했고요.
홈매 업적 코멘트가 제일 좋았는데
비수기임에도 불구하고 사업 실적이
매우 호조를 보이고 있고 가격은
안정적이고 보용 수준도 양호하고
공급망도 경고하다라고
어 코멘트를 해 줬습니다. 전력
쪽에서도 어 납기 지연 공급망약 자재
부족 이런 가격 변동성이 좀 확대되고
있다고 했고요. 오매 쪽에서는 가격
인상에 힘입어 어 매출이 지속적으로
증가 중이라고 얘기하면서 어 대체로
어 비용 증가 병목 뭐 공급 부족
납기 지연 그리고 어 일부 그 잘되는
수요가 강한 쪽에서의서도
이제 어 공급망차질 요런 부분들이 좀
관찰되고 있고 어 소비 쪽은 어
소매업 쪽 그 코멘트를 보면은 는 어
상당히 견조한 걸로 어 파악이 되고
있습니다.
그래서 앞에서 그
ISM 제조업 지수 내에 아 물가
지수가 있는데 물가 지수가
이번에 그 6월 대비해서 아 5월대
매수 6월에 좀 하락했다고 했고 다음
주에 또 CPI가 어 발표가
남아 있기 때문에 그 부분이 어 7월
29일 날 어 FMC 그 의사 결정에
상당한 영향을 미칠 수 있기 때문에
어 계속해서 저도
좀 예민하게 하게 보고 있는 편인데
어 제조업하고 서비스업 물가는 4월에
일단은 픽아웃 조짐이 관찰되고 있는
거 같습니다.
밑에 이제 월별 ISM 물가 지수하고
어 미국
CP 아 CPI 추위를 보면은 어
1, 2, 3월로 가면 갈수록 그이
전쟁 어 영향으로 인해서 어 4,
5월까지 또 그 계속해서 어
제조업이라든지 서비스업 어 물가가
올라가는 것이 어 보이는데요.
제 같은 경우 4월에 물가 지수가
84.6을
찍었다가 5월에 82.1, 6월에
73으로 빠지고 있고요. 그리고
서비스업 같은 경우 어 5월에 그
71.3 그리고 6월에 67.7
그래서 어 데이터로만 보면은 제주업은
4월에 픽아웃하는 모습이고
서비스업은 그보다 한 달 좀 늦은
5월에 픽아웃하는 모습들이 관찰이
되고 있습니다. 그리고
[목을 가다듬음]
6월은 그 5월보다 좀 빠지고 있는
어 두 그 제조업이나 서비스업이 다
빠지고 있는 모습이고요.
밑에 이제 헤드라인하고 코어 CPI
보면은 어 5월에 4.2%가 2%가
헤드라인이었고
2.9가 코어였는데 어 일단은 6월에
지금 블룸버그나 클리블랜드 연원에서
추정하고 있는 헤드라인 CPI는
3.9로 어 지금 추정이 되고 있고
코어 쪽은 이게 서비스 쪽인하고 많이
연관이 되는데 굉장히 스티키 2.9로
어 잘 안 빠지는 그런 모습들이 어
보이고 있습니다. 일단 시장에서는
그렇게 보고 있고요.
어 2022년
그 아 앞에 이제 그 제조업하고
서비스 물가
>> 그 약간의 선행성에 대해서 어 말씀을
드렸는데 어 밑에 그 제조업 물가하고
서비스 물가 그리고 CPI
어 이쪽을 좀 관찰를 해 보시면은
2022년에 어 러우 전쟁 어
일어났었던 당시에도 어 CPI보다
제조업이나 서피스 물가가 약간
선행에서 좀 먼저 픽아웃하는 모습이
어 보였고요. 그 이후에 어 CPI가
어 한두 달 정도 후행해서 어
픽아웃하는 모습들이 관찰이 됐습니다.
이번에도 보시면은
그 어 제조업 물가가 파란색이고
서비스업 물가가 아 빨간색인데
제조업이 이미 2026년 4월에 두
달 전에 어 픽아웃했고요. 그리고 어
서비스 물가는 이번에 아저 그 이번에
발표한 거에 의하면은 어 5월에
픽아웃 한 거로 어 보여지고
있습니다. 그리고 아 지금 CPI
같은 경우는 어 5월에 4.2%
그리고 이번 6월에 시장에서
추정되는게 3.9%로 9%로 약간 뭐
요것도 이제 시차를 한두 달 두고 어
제조업이나 서비스업 물가 그리고 CP
요런 순으로 좀 어 내려오는 모습들이
어 관찰되는데 물론 이제 어 6월 달
지표가 아직 안 나왔기 때문에 뭐
서꾸르게 단정할 순 없겠지만 과거
사례를 좀 보고 지금 그 어떤
돌아가는 여건을 볼 때 시장
컨센서스하고 좀 비슷하게 나오지
않을까라는 생각인데 그 밑에 이제 그
항목별 CPI 기어도 쪽을 좀 더
보시면은음
이번에 미일한 전쟁 이후에
어떤 항목들이 어 CPI에 크게
기어를 했는지 이렇게 어 색깔별로
나와 있는데 녹색이 지금
에너지입니다. 에너지가 그 3월 달
이전만 하더라도 거의 CPI에 기어를
하지 못했다가 어 3 45 보면은
기어도가 상당히 높아지고 5월 달에
기어도가 가장 높습니다. 그래서 대충
막대기로 보면 한 1점 한 4 5%
정도 퍼센 정도 어 기여를 했을 걸로
어 예상이 되고요.요 요 부분이 사실
어 그 기어 율 자체가 유가가
떨어지면서 기어도가 낮아지게 되면은
어 전체 헤드라인 CPI 최소한
헤드라인 CPI는 낮아질 수
있겠다라는 어 생각이 들고요.
그래서이 1.45 4% 1.4%에서지
1.5% 5% 정도니까이 부분이 전부
언제 빠질지 모르겠지만 전부 다
빠지게 되면은 다시 CPI는 어
정상으로 뭐 2점 다른 조건이
동일하다고 할 때 어 2점
2%대 중후반 정도까지 어 내려올
가능성이 어 있어 보입니다.
그리고 어 에너지 쪽에서 가장 그
영향력이 큰 어 WTI를 보면은 어
CPI하고 WTI의 좀 관계를 좀
그려봤는데요. 어, 가장 뭐 그
가까운 사례로 어, 22년 어,
유가가 강하게 어, 전쟁 이슈로
인해서 올랐을 때 CPI하고
그 WTI하고 어, 대체로요
픽아웃하는 시점 자체가 어, 동일하게
나타났습니다. 그래서 이번에 보면은
어 유가 뭐 장 중에 120불까지도
어 올라갔지만 어 종가 기준으로 해서
100불 이상에서 어 유지되던
구간에서 어 CPI가 사실상 세게
올라갔고요. 어 그렇게 본다면은 어
이전에 2022년처럼
WTI나 CPI가 대체로 비슷한
시점에 유상하게 픽아웃 되지
않을까라는 생각이 좀 어 있고요.
그리고 시장에서도 조금 어이를
반영하듯이 어 패드워치에서 어 6월
26일 날 어 그 추정된 어이 7월
29일 FOMC 금리 동결 확률
자체가 70.6%였는데
7월 6일 날 보니까 이게
74.9%로 9%로 어 동결확률이
조금 올라갔고요.이
이 이후에 뭐 인상 확률 자체는 뭐
가봐야 되겠지만 인상 확률 자체도
조금씩 어이
9월 달 보면은 조금 내려왔고 어
다른 밑에 부분들은 뭐 크게 의미는
없을 것 같아서 어쨌든 어 다음 주에
나오는 CPI가 상당히 그 시장의
색깔과
방향성 요런 부분들에 어 중요한
역할을 할 거 같아서 좀 자세히
들어다봤습니다. 이상입니다.
>> 네. 감사합니다.
최근 시장 설명할 때 어 왜 시장이
그렇게 시원하게 못 치고 가는가?
네. 그 부분을이 금리 금리가 이제
바지가를 딱 붙잡고 있는 그런
모습이라고 설명을 좀 드리면서 최근에
CPI가 2.4에서 4.2까지 좀
올라오다 보니까요 부분이 좀
관건이다. 그런데 이번에 월드컵
때문에 다음 주에 발표 6월까지는
예상치보다는 조금 높을 수 있지만
유가라든지 그다음에 뭐 지금 보여
주셨던 여러 가지 데이터를 보면음
결국은 꺾이게 돼 있기 때문에 그래서
이번
7, 8월
7월 오히려 조정을 좀 먼저 맞고
오히려 8, 9월로 가면 어 CPI가
확실하게 좀 가파르게 떨어지네. 이런
모습이 오히려 8월 CPI 데이터
나올 때는 좀 의미 있게 이번에 좀
뭐 3,9까지 안 떨어지더라도 8월
달에는 오히려 뭐 3% 대가 지금
나올 거라고 보거든요.
>> 예. 그러면서 시장이 이제 환호하면서
10년 국제 금리도 좀 떨어지고
그러면서
반등이 좀 들어가고 내년 되면 오히려
CPI가 좀 더 떨어지는 모습이
나오면서 좀 연말부터 내년 상반기까지
아주 더 강세량 펼쳐지지 않을까?
>> 예. 그런 얘기를 말씀 계속 말씀을
많이 드리거든요.이
>> 과거 CPI 추위 요렇게 쭉 이런
거를 한번 오늘 우리 최부 사장요
자료를
굉장히 중요한 부분입니다. 이게 과거
미국 시장이나 한국 시장이나 특히
미국 시장에는이 물가와 연동되면서
금리가 어느 정도 임계점을 좀 터치를
할 때가 항상 조정이 있는데
>> 지금 4.4% 4% 이걸 제가
목욕탕에
공탕 온도가 44도 45도 하면 아
뜨겁다고 말씀드린 것처럼
>> 맞습니다.
개별 종목
단에서도 뭐 개별 종목의 개별 기업의
리스크 이런 것도 있긴 하지만
전체적인 시장의
약세원이나
금리
>> 금리는 말씀드린 대로
>> 진짜이 CPI 자료 요렇게 쭉 보다
보니까 어 더더욱 좀 확신이 되네요.
>> 가방기 장이 상당히 좋겠다.
>> 감사합니다.
>> 네.
자, 그러면 어 국내 시장으로 넘어가
보도록 하겠습니다.
네, 전일 시장 말씀드리겠습니다.
코스피 수 0.46% 하락
마감했었고요.
코스닥이 -2.46% 46% 하락
마감했습니다. 어 포스피지 수의
변동성이 굉장히 컸었던 하루였고요.
수급적으로 봐 주시면 개인 투자자가
어제 2조 6천후가량
매수를 했었고 반면에 외국인의 매도는
뭐 여전히 나오고 있습니다. 1조
3천억대 매도가 나왔었고요.
기관에서도 한 3거래일 연속 매도세가
나오고 있는데 어제장에서 한 1조
4천억 가량에 매도 물량이
나왔습니다. 외인 선물에서는 1조
넘게 매도가 있었고요. 어 아래
투자자별 매매 동향으로 내려갔었으면
외국인 투자자는 어제 기아, 대덕
전자, 서신 시스템, 신세계, 현대
로템, 테스, PSK, 삼성 SDI
등을 매수했었고요.
반면 매도 쪽에는 삼성전자
6,400억 국가량 매도가 있었고 그
외에 삼성전기, SK퀘어, SK
하이닉스, KB 금융, 미래세 증권
등을 매도했습니다. 기관 매수에는
삼성전자 우선축, KB 금융, 삼성
불산, 기아 현대차등을 매수했고요.
매도에는 SK닉스, 삼성전기, SK
스퀘어, SDI, 효성 중공업,
하나오션 등을 매도했습니다.
52주 신고가 종목 총 여덟
종목인데요. 여전히 좀 개수 자체
적습니다. 코스피에서 신한 지주
그리고 KB 발에 인프라 남광토원
한국 주강 등이 신고가였고 어
코스닥에서 YG1원 그리고 골프존
홀딩스 대원 등이 신고가의 이름을
올렸습니다.음
음. 외국인 동령이나 기관 동양에서
전자 외국인은
전자랑 아 밑에 보니까 하이넥스도 뭐
같이 팔긴 팔았네. 네.
>> 어 팔았고
>> 기관은 보니깐
기관도 하이닉스로 좀
근데 화이닉스랑 어제 전자 주가가 왜
이렇게 엇갈렸어요?
전사는 확실히 오늘 실적 발표가
예정이 되어 있었기 때문에 좀
기대감이 반영이 됐던 거 같고 그리고
최근에 주가 하락도 보면 전자가 좀
더 못 올랐었고 더 많이 빠졌었기
때문에
>> 그런 부분이 주가에 영향을 미쳤었던게
아닌가 생각이
>> 그리고 뭐 파운더리 쪽이 흑자 전환
얘기가 나오던데 그거는 어제 장중에는
나왔어요 아니면
>> 어제 장중에 예. 본 거 같습니다.
>> 어, 마음의 흑자 여기 이번 3분기
정도면 흑자 전환할 수 있다라는게 한
3, 4개월 전에 나왔던 얘기잖아요.
>> 네. 네.
>> 어, 근데 실제로 흑자 전환이 이번
2분기 실적에는 나오는게 아니라
3분기에 흑자 전환할 수 있다. 이거
>> 3분기상이 좀 더 높을 것 같고요.
4난노에서 이제 물량들을 저희가 많이
받아 가지고 흑전 1등 공시 된 거
같습니다.
>> 아, 그래요?
습니다. 자, 일단 리포트 아,
그 주요 종목들 동령 보고 리포트가
조금 전에 말씀하셨던 메리츠 김선우
연구원에
>> 예, 삼성전자
리포트 나온게 있으니까 리포트
내용하고 오늘 잠정 실적 발표한
내용하고
같이 보도록 하겠습니다. 일단 먼저
주요 종목 대통령 한번 보겠습니다.
네. 반도체 섹터 먼저 살펴보면 어제
전자의 주가는 2.7% 그래도
상승으로 마감하면서 끝났고요.
데스케아닉스의 주가는 약 3%가량
하락으로 마감을 했습니다. 그래서
결국에는 또 PER P로 아직은 보진
않지만 P밸루에이션이 SK하이닉스와
전자와 또 비슷해지는 상황이 왔고요.
꽤 괴리율이 컸었거든요. 두 회사에
닉스가 좀 더 하락하면서 거의
키맞추기가 되는 상황입니다. 아래
소부장 쪽으로 보면
좀 흐름이 안 좋습니다. 최근 흐름이
안 좋은데요. 원스 기준으로 보면은
거의 다 파란색으로 다 변했죠.
그런데
>> 한미반도 최복 2.6% 하락했고 뭐
리노구이나 HPSP 이런 종목들
대체로 다 약세로 마감을 했고요.
HPSP는 저 PR이 업데이트가 안
되는데 한 20 800까지 빠진
상황입니다. 그래서 리노공업 뭐 파
어 주성 엔지니어링 원익 IPS
ISC 심텍 뭐 대체로 5% 이상의
낙폭을 보였었고요. 그 외
이수페타시스도 8% 가량 급락세를
보였습니다. 지금 워먼스 기준으로
대체로 다 뭐 많게나 20% 적게는
10% 이상씩 약세 흐름을 보이면서
밸루에이션이 많이 그래도 내려온
상황입니다. 뭐 리노은 27배까지
빠져 있는 상황이고요. 뭐 이오유크
같은 경우 40배 위로 갔다가 다시
35배까지
내려온 상황입니다.
IT 섹터로 내려가서 보면 삼성
전기가 8% 가량 크게 하락했습니다.
뭐 특별한 이슈는 없었고요. 후재는
계속 들리는데 어 최근에 주가 조정이
좀 나타나고 있는 거 같습니다. 뭐
여전히 그래도 원스 기준으로는 플러스
흐름을 유지 중에 있는 상황이고요.
그 아래 LG 전자 그리고 뭐
LG노텍, LG 디스플레이, 파이텍
등은 또 금 크게 또 하락하는
종목들도 일부 있었던 거 같습니다.
젠슨왕 온다 했을 때 LG 전자 같은
기업들,
LG CNS 이런 기업들 많이
올랐었는데 그때가 그냥 반짝이었고
다시 펀더를 찾아가는 흐름이 나타나고
사실 개인 투자분들이 굉장히 많이
매수했던 [콧방귀]
종목 중에 하나로 알고 있는데
>> 항상 저문이 말씀하셨지만 지금은 금
고금리 상황이기 때문에 실적이
받쳐주지 않고 네러티브로 오는
종목들은 조심해야 된다 하는게
이번에도 좀 드러났던 거 같고요.
>> -38.7% 7% 한 달 만에 내가
>> 저때 얘기 들렸던 건 뭐 로봇부터 해
가지고 뭐 MB랑 협업을 한다는 막
이런 얘기 많았었거든요. 네. 뭐
그런 부분이 사실 실적에 반영되기는
지금 좀 힘든 구간이기 때문에 뭐
주가는 그대로 다 내려온 사항이고
이노텍도 저번에 말씀드렸지만 그
플리치 BJ 사업부의 매출 비중이
10%임에도 불구하고 영원님들이
LG 이노텍 전사실적에 BJ 멀티플을
부여했었다라고 말씀을 드려서 좀 이거
비싼 거 같다라고 했었는데 전기와는
확실히 주가 흐름이 좀 달라지는
흐름이 나타나고 있는 상황입니다.
입니다. 어, 그리고 플랫폼 섹터는
네이버, 카카오, 보합 정도 지하면서
뭐 시장 대비로는 양호했던 거
같습니다. 네이버가 또 14배가
됐습니다. 그래서 밸루에이션이 많이
착해진 상황이고요. 니케이 지수
전일장의 보합 정도 수준으로 마감을
했는데 어, 장비주 쪽이나 반도체 쪽
대체로 안 좋았던 거 같습니다. 도쿄
일렉트론 그리고 무라타, 호야,
이비덴 등이 약세 흐름을 보였고요.
그래서 삼성전기의 피어라고 볼 수
있는 물라타나 이비덴도 전기와 주가
흐름이 비슷한 양상이었습니다.
그리고 자동차 섹터로 넘어가서 보면
어 자동차 섹터 나쁘지 않았습니다.
현대차가 2% 상승했고요. 기아
5.7, 모비스도 4.2%
상승 마감했습니다. 그래서 현대차가
어떻게 될지 모르겠지만 대체로
10열배에서는 또 주가가 반등이
나오더라고요. 그래서이 부분은 좀
유심히 봐야 되지 않을까라는 생각이고
소비자 섹터는 생건 어 코스트맥스
상승세를 보였고요.
코스메카 코리아도 보합 정도였습니다.
어 피부 미용 기기로 보면 어제 좀
안 좋았습니다. 파마리 서치가 8%
하락했고 클래시스나 휴젤 등도
약세흐름을 보였습니다. 최근에 주가가
좀 그래도 반등세를 보였었는데 어
전장에서는 상승분을 좀 반납하는
아쉬운 흐름이 나왔던 거 같고요.
아래 음식료 섹터는 대체로 부진한
흐름 유지를 했고 백화점 체인도
부진했습니다.
조선 철강 및 기타 섹터 봐 주시면
현대중공업 1% 상승 하나 오전이
8.6% 6%
상승으로 마감했는데요. 어, 간밤에
좀 아쉬운 소식이 들려오긴 했는데
독일 경쟁사한테
어, 캐나다 잠수함 사업이 독일
경쟁사로 넘어갔다라는 소식이
나왔습니다. 그래서 전일장의 기대감에
하나 오션이 좀 많이 올랐었는데요.
>> 음. 독일 TKMS 쪽으로 수주가
나가면서 하나 오선는 저번에 좀
떨어진게 아닌가 생각이 듭니다.
주가는 뭐 어쩔 수 없이 맞긴 해야
될 거 같은데요. 어제 이제
기대감으로 8% 올랐었기 때문에
>> 음
>> 근데 뭐 밸류가 비싼 상황에서 악재가
나오면 모르겠는데 밸류가 그래도 많이
내려온 상황에서 악재가 나와서
뭐 단기적으로 반등하시기는 힘들 수
있겠지만 뭐 여기서 주가가 뭐
빠진다고 해서 팔기 만약 가지고 계신
분들이라면 팔기는 좀 아쉽지 않나
그런 생각도 좀 듭니다. 그리고 아래
내려가서 방산 업체들로 보면 하나
에어로 약세였고요. 로템도
약세였습니다. 넥스은 그래도 한
1.8% 가량 상승 마감했고요.
글로벌 방산 업체 대비 국내 방산이
지금 상당히 많이 약합니다. 어
소해가 좀 글로벌리로 보면 나오고
있는데 결국 이런 부분은 해소되지
않을까라는 생각이고요.
바이오섹터는 대체로 부진한 흐름
나왔습니다. 어 삼성 바이오나 에피스
홀딩스 셀트리온 코스닥 바이오 대체로
약세 흐름이었고요. 어제 증권주들
흐름 나쁘지 않았습니다. 키움 증권을
비롯해서 한국 금융주 미래세 증권
대체로 상승하는 흐름이 나왔었고요.
엔토 쪽이 좋았습니다. 특별한 이슈는
없었고요. 하이브가 4.8 GPS
SMYG 올라가면서 확실히 밸루에이션
메리트가 올라온 업종이기 때문에
수급이 좀 들어오는 거 같고요.
연합기 쪽은 최근에 흐름이 안
좋습니다. 현대 1렉 뭐 효성 중공
LS 1렉 다 안 좋고요. 현대
1렉은 지난주에 어 1조원 때
수공시가 나왔음에도 불구하고 주가가
약세 흐름을 이어나가고 있고요.
포워드 밸류로 현대 1 30배,
효성중업 30배까지 많이 내려온
상황입니다.
[목을 가다듬음]
자, [목을 가다듬음] 주요 종목들
동영상은 이제 쭉 훑어봤고요.
어, 삼성전자 리포트하고 그다음에도
어, 또 반도체 리포트니까
어, 삼성전자 잠정 실청 나온 김에
한번 오늘 반도체 쭉 한번
봐 보도록 하겠습니다. 메리츠 김선우
연구원의 제목은 삼성전자 반도체
충당전 110조원
압도적 수익성 재확인이 될 거다라는
거였죠. 리포트 내용이.
>> 네. 어제 나온 리포트였고요.
>> 실제는 뭐 88조 정도 이익이 나왔고
[콧방귀]
충단금 제외하고 한 108조 정도의
이익이 나온 거다라고 봐 주시면
되는데요.
>> 2분기 추정을 연구님은 90조로
전망을 했었습니다. 그래서 시장
컨센이 한 86조 정도까지
올라왔었는데 일을 좀 상해할 것으로
예상을 했었고요. 어쨌든 뭐 잘
맞추셨다라고 볼 수 있을 것 같고
메모리 판가와 출화량이 산업 평균을
크게 웃는 것이 핵심 요인으로 돌
수가 있는데요. 이번 분기부터 DS
특별 성가급 충단금이 반영
시작됐습니다. 그래서 1분기 충단금도
이번 2분기에 소급 반영될 것으로
예상을 했는데 이번에 좀 반영이 된
거 같고요. 컨센서스에는 충당금
일부만 반영된 것으로 보여서 실제
실적은 시장 기대치를 크게 상의할
가능성이 높다라고 판단을 했습니다.
DS 부분 충단적 영업 이익은
109조 정도로 추정을 했었고요.
어 1분기 소급 충단금 8 5.6조랑
2분기 충단금 13.7조원을 7조원을
반영을 했다라고 합니다. 그래서
메모리 사업 부충단전 이익은 영업
이익 기준으로 112조원으로
추정을 했었고요. LSI나 파운드리는
가동률 확대 영향으로 영업 손실 2조
정도 나올 것으로 예상을 했습니다.
SDC 영업 이익은 5,800억 정도
예상을 했고요. DX는
어 DX는 좀 잘린 거 같은데요.
MX가 -1조원, DVD가
1,500억 정도 적자 전환 전망을
했고요. 메모리 가격 상승으로 부품
원가 부담까지 확대되면서 세트 사업은
판가 인상과 판매량 감소가 불가피할
것으로 전망을 했습니다. 연말까지는
메모리 가격 산승이 지속될 것으로
전망을 했는데요. 올해 사상 최대
실적을 분기마다 경신할 것으로 예상을
했습니다. 클린룸론 부족에 따른 공급
부족이 여전히 좀 지속이 되고
있고요. B2C 비중은 감소하는
반면에 AI용 메모리 지원 확대될
전망을 했습니다. CSP들은 LTA와
전략적 협력을 통해서 메모리 확보를
지속할 것으로 예상을 했고요.
27년은 메모리 수급 더욱 타이트할
것으로 전망을 했습니다. 현재 메모리
사이클은 아직 미드 사이클에도
도달하지 못한 것으로 보고 있다라고
하고요. 공급은 최소 27년
4분기까지 수요 증가를 따라가기는
어려울 것이다. 그래서 전자의 실적
개선 속도가 가장 빠를 것으로 예상이
돼서 적극적 비중 확대를 공고했고요.
4분기 주조환원 정책 발표가 주가
재평가의 계기가 될 전망이다. 3개년
주조원 규모는 100조원 정도로
가정을 했고요. 연말 추가 배당은
주당 14,800원 정도로 가성을
했고 자사주 매입 소각 병행 가능성도
존재한다. 투자 회견은 바이 TP는
50만 원으로 사용 조정을 했습니다.
그래서 이번에 뭐 충당급 성가급
반영이 됐는데요.
9조 정도 반영이 된 거 같고 1분기
때이 영업 이익의 10.5%거든요.
5%거든요. 1분기 5.6조
에다가 2분기 한 13조 14조 정도
반영이 된 숫자가 이번 이익에 잡힌
거 같습니다. 아래 실적 추정치로
내려가서 보면 올해 예상 매출액이
745조입니다.
그리고 영업 이익 기준으로 보면
오른쪽에 있는데요. 영업 이익이 올해
예상이 388조 전망으로 되어
있고요. 내년은 거의 매출이
1,000조입니다. 그래서 965조에
영업 이익 575조
전망이 되고 있고요. 어제
UBS에서는 삼성전자의 영업익을
800조 이상으로 보더라고요. 내년
영업 이익을.
>> 음.
하이닉스가 한 600조였나
그렇게 지금 추정을 하고 있는데
UBS는 워낙 좀 블리시한 케이스로
항상 추정을 하기 때문에 그런
숫자까지 지금 최근에 나오고 있는
흐름입니다.
그리고 아래 LSI 그 이제 파운드리
쪽도 봐 주시면 일단 메리츠 김선우
연구원
님은 올해
3분기도 여전히 좀 적자로는 보고
있는 거 같고요. 4분기 되면 BP
수준으로 보는 거 같습니다. 그럼에도
불구하고 내년도 적자로 여전히 추정을
하고 있는 거 같고요. 아직까지는 뭐
숫자가 찍힌 적이 없기 때문에 좀
보수적으로 판단을 하고 있는 것으로
보여지고요.
그래서 영업 이익이
어 분기로 보면 지금 어쨌든 내려가는
증가율 자시 내려가는 추위는
맞거든요. 여기 오른쪽에 1q 2 3
4 나오는데
영업 이익이 1분기때 57조 2분기
90조 어 88조다. 나왔죠. 그리고
3기 112조, 4분기 128조기
때문에 이거를 기울기로 보면은 어쨌든
우하향하는 추세로 접어드는
상황이다라고 볼 수가 있는데 저희가
이제 기대해야 될 부분은 HBM 가격
협상이거든요. 그래서 최근에 리포트들
나오는 거 보니까
HBM 내년 가격이 100% 인상될
것이다라는 전망이 나오고 있거든요.
그 가격 협상이 7, 8월 달에
확정되는 걸로 알고 있는데 근데
100%는 모르겠지만 큰 폭의 인상은
분명히 나올 수밖에 없다라고
생각하는게 지금 디램 마진이 H밴
마진보다 훨씬 높은 상황이잖아요.
음.
>> 그게 사실 말이 안 되는 거기 때문에
>> 음. 가격 인상은 무조건 나타날
거다라는 생각이 들고 그래서 내년에이
기울기가이 우하향하던 추세가 다시
올라가는게 HBM 가격에 따라 좀
결정이 될 거 같다 생각이 듭니다.
자, 그리고 밑에 대신 유영근
연구원의 반체의 얘기도이어서 그냥
읽어보죠, 뭐.
>> 네. 어 끝없이 펼쳐질 실크로드라고
해서 대신 유형근 연구 자료였는데요.
메모리 센트릭이라고 해서 경고해지는
성벽이라고 합니다. 한국 반도체
업종에 대한 적극적 매수 의견을
제화인 했고요. 삼성전자 목표 주가
56만 원 유지했고 하이닉스의
기준으로는 390만 원까지 사양
조정을 했습니다.
>> 최근에 리포드들 흐름이 전자와 닉세
주가가 사실 고천 대비한 20%
이상씩 빠졌었잖아요. 그럼에도
불구하고 목표 주가도 올리고 의견
자체는 좀 더 불리시하게 가는 상황인
거 같습니다. 몇 가지 이유를 좀
꼽았는데요.네 가지입니다. 첫 번째
잔파도는 큰 흐름을 바꾸지 못한다라고
하고요. 어 메모리 반도체 초후한
국면은 여전히 유효하다라고 보고
있는데 AI 수요는 지속 확대되는
반면 생상 증가는 제한적이어서 27년
공급 부족 강도는 26년 대비 더욱
심화될 것으로 전반했습니다. 4년도
고객요가 구차화되는 3분기에는 극심한
수급 격차가 다시 한번 확인될
가능성이 높다라고 하고요. 최근 주가
변동성은 높은 절대 주가 수준과 테크
주식 쏠림에 따른 단기 이슈 민감도
확대 영향으로 판단을 한다. 그래서
AI팩스 지속 가능성이나 중국 반도체
대체 가능성, 메모리 가격 담 우려
등 시장에서 제기된 이슈들은 시간이
지나면서 해소될 가능성이 높다라고
보고 있고요. 업사이클 과정에서
나타난 일시적 줄다리기 정도로 보고
있고 결국 주가는 상승 추세 이어갈
것으로 본다. 어, 두 번째는
LTA의 가치 확대인데 LTA의 기본
구조는 3년 이상 장기 계약이라고
하고요. 계약금의 10에서 한 30%
수준을 손금으로 지급을 한다고
합니다. 가격 밴드 설정 형태로
구성될 가능성이 높다라고 하고요.
특히 계약 연장 옵션이 핵심이라고
하는데 계약 종료 직전에 연장 여부를
결정하는 것이 아니라 계약 기간 중
조기의 연장 여부를 논의하는 구조라면
공급 업체는 고객의 실제 수요를 훨씬
정확하게 파악할 수 있을 거다라는
이야기를 했습니다.이를 통해 공급
운영의 정확도를 높이고 메모리 사업의
고실적인 사이클 변동성을
완화하는 효과를 기대한다
이야기했습니다. 그래서 저 위에 가격
밴드 설정에 대한 이야기를 했잖아요.
최근에 들리는 이야기로는 하이닉스는
상한은 없다라고 하더라고요. 이제
마이크론과 삼성전단은 상한이 좀
존재한다 뭐 이런 이야기가 있기는
합니다. 세 번째는 HBM 중심
ASP 상승 사이클이 다시 한번
재개될 것이다라는 전망인데요. 27년
HBM ASP는 전년 대비 100%
이상 올라갈 것으로 보고 있는데 기본
시나리오는 100% 이상이지만
협상하에 따라 상승폭은 추가 확대될
가능성도 열어놓고 보자. 이야기까지
했습니다. 범영 디램 수익성이
HBM보다 높아지는 현상을 방지하고
전제품고 공급 부족 환경을 활용해서
가격 인상을 추진 중이라고 하고요.
고객사와의 장기 파트너십을
유지하면서도 수익성을 극대화하는 가격
정책이 이어질 것으로 전망을
했습니다. 어네 번째는 역대 최대
규모의 주주 환원을 우리가 기대해
보자라고 하는데요. 어 삼성전선자
SK닉스 모두 역대 최대 규모
주조하는 정책 시행 가능성이 높아지고
있다라고 합니다. 연간 현금 흐름이
구체화되는 3분기 실적 발표 이후에
어 정책 방향이 보다 명확해지지
않을까라는 전망이고요. 양사 모두 약
100조원 규모의 주주 환원이 가능한
재무 여력을 보유한 것으로 추정을
했습니다.
아래 표로 내려가서 보면 글로벌
메모리 반도체 시장 규모 추위 및
전망 표인데요. 어 27년이 되면
1600 빌리언 달러 정도로
>> 보고 있는 거 같습니다. 시장 규모
자체를 그리고 성장률로 보면 일단
26년이 성장률에 피크긴 한 거
같아요. 그다음에 내년 되면은 쭉
떨어지는 흐름으로 추정은 하고 있는
거 같고요. 오른쪽은 HBM 시장
규모 추위 및 전망입니다.
180빌리언 달러 168빌리언 달러
정도로 27년에 크게 성장할 것으로
보고 있는데요. 일단 H4가
어 내년에 이제 본격화 될 예정이고
그리고 가격 인상분을 아마 반영을
해서 168빌리언 달러로 찍어 놓으신
것 같습니다. 한 100% 정도
올라갈 거다라고 추정을 해 놓고 보는
거 같고요. 그래서 Y와Y 그로스로
보면이 시장 규모 자체는 200%
정도 커질 거다라고 보는 거
같습니다. [콧방귀] 오른쪽은 디램
3사의 제고수주 아 주수 수입및
전망인데요.
정상 제고에 한참 못 미친 못 미치는
재고 레벨로 내려가 있다라고 볼 수
있어서 재고가
높았을 때는 거의 25주였는데 지금
뭐 제고 주가 없습니다. 그냥 수주
나오는 대로 바로바로 나가는 상황이고
제 재고가 [목을 가다듬음] 부족한
상황이다라고 저희가 해석을 하면 될
것 같습니다.
음.이
이 재고 차트 이렇게 장기적으로 보는
건 처음 보네. 어, 컴퍼니 A,
B, C 하면 뭐 메모리 3 4일
거고 그죠?
정상적인 제고는
한요 3주에서 8주.
>> 네.요
사이 정도가 정상적인 재구
수준인데어야
23년에
재구가 진짜 많기 많았었네 그때 어
>> 그때 뭐 제고만 얼마라 그랬더라
50조원 채
그러면서
이런 걸 보면 어 반도체 그
반도체가이 이 사이클이
그 붙임이 좀 심한 모습을 과거에는
보여 왔었었는데 그죠? 이제 제국가
부족해지면서 위에 얘기됐던 것처럼이
단연계야이 LTA로 좀 반도체
사이클이 좀 완만해졌으면 좋겠어요.
그죠?
>> 예.
투자자도 그렇고 실제 사업을 하시는이
사업체들도 그렇고
>> 어 굉장히 이
>> 붙침이 심하다 보니까 이익이 많이
났다가 또 흉년이 났다가
그런 구조였었는데
어 지금은 보니까 재고가 아예 없네.
그냥 빵이네. 빵
만드는 족쪽 그죠? 맞는 족쪽 지금
다 내보내야 되다 보니까
요때 보니까 2018년 1큐부터
제고가 바닥을 치고 스물스물
올라오는데
주식을 언제 팔아야 되는가?
어이 컴파니 A가 어딘지 뭐 이런 건
모르시죠?
>> 네.
일단 첫째가 2019년 1Q로 갈
때는 제고가 이제 꽉 늘어났을 때고
확실히 재고가 늘어나니까 2019년
1큐부터 어닝 쇼크가 나오기
시작하는데 사실 18년 4Q부터 4Q
실적을 발표하는 19년 1월 잠정
실적 발표부터가 이제 쇼크가 나오기
시작했었거든요.
앞큐부터.
그렇게 보니까이 재고가 확실히 바닥을
치고 올라가는데
2분기 연속이
재고가 우상향할 때 어 주식을 팔아야
되나? 어, 지금 방금 그런 생각이
좀 들었고요.
21년 22년 23년
21년도에
5월 달인가 그때 하이닉스
고점이 나왔었으니까도
바닥 치고 올라오는데
[목을 가다듬음] 마이크로는 20
1년
12월 달에 그래도
살짝 신고가 나고 이제 떨어졌었는데
근데이
컴퍼니 C 제가
훨씬 더 빠르게 올라왔었네.
이때 당시는
>> 컴파니 C가
충분히 재고를 갖고 있었던 약간 그런
느낌이 드는데
컴파니 C가 삼성전자인가 뭐 그런
느낌도 좀 들고
아무튼 어이 제고 추위로만 보면
아직은
이것만 보니까 메모리
[목을 가다듬음] 3 4의 주가가
고점이 아니다는 생각이 또 드면 그죠
예네 음.
>> 그죠? 이게 잠깐만 27년 1Q니까
아 이거 예상치까지 다 반영이
된다네.네
>> 맞습니다. 한 저기 점선 세 개 정도
예상치
>> 그렇네요. 26년
지금 이번에 실적 발표된게 2Q니까
지금 저 그림은 2017 아
2027년 내년까지는
계속 재고가 부족할 거다. 아 그걸
반영한 거죠.
저 그림대로 되면 그러니까 주가는
고점이 아니에요.
>> 계속 근데 제고를 어떻게 계속 체크를
좀 체크가 돼요? 제고가
>> 제고는 이제 아B 레포트들에서 이제
간간히 언급을 해 주시고 있고요.
그게 아니면은 분기 제접 발표 이후에
체크할 수 있습니다.
>> 어. 아, 분기 실적 발표 이후에
체크가
>> 예.
근데 최근에 여기 컴파니 B 같은
약간 어 회색 회색은 보니까 제고
레벨이 살짝 올라오는 것처럼 또
보이네.
>> 네.
>> 올라오는 것처럼 보이다가
다시 급격하게 떨어질 거다라고
예상치다. 그죠? 저거는.
>> 네.
>> 하여튼 잘 봐야 될 거 같네 보니까.
그리고 여기서 HBM 시장 규모랑
글로벌 메모리 시장 규모 나오는데 그
과거와 1992년부터
나오네요. 자료가
>> 네네. 짝기열입니다. 요번에
성적률이고 막대 그래프가이
시장 규모일 때 어 그동안에는이
메모리 반도체 다 합쳐 봐야 사실 그
200빌년 2,억 정도도 안 되는
규모였기 때문에 그래서 메모리 쪽이
200조 비메모리 쪽이 한 600조
그래서 총 한 800조 요렇게 시장
규모였었는데 최근에 이제 급등을
하면서 서
이게 1400년
달러까지 그죠? 규모가 늘어났으니까
2,조 시장이 돼 버렸어요. 200조
시장에서 2,조 시장이 지금 돼 있는
상황이고이 중에서도 HBM이
차지하는게 아직까지는 15%
수준이네요.
>> 네. 지금 한 15에서 20% 정도
사이라고 보시면
>> 그러면 HBM은 스페셜티 반도체니까
메모리 3, 4 중에 아까 우과정이
얘기했듯이 원래는 HBM 쪽이 마진이
좋고
>> 네티이 원래 [목을 가다듬음] 법용이
>> 철각 색깔 되고 했었다가 최근에
DDR4부터 DDR 5가 급행을
하면서 어 HBM보다도 오히려 그냥
비램이 마진이 지금 더 비싸단
말이죠.
>> 네. 예. 원래 HBM 마진이 50%
대였어요. 마진이. 그래서 굉장히
높은 마진이었죠. 저희가 이제
재작년부터 추적을 했는데.
>> 네네.
>> 근데 HBM을 비롯해서 서버향으로
워낙 물량들이 나가다 보니까
레거시티램이 소티지가 나고요.
지금까지도 마진이 고공 엔진을 하고
있는 상황입니다.
>> 그래서 HBM 가격을 올릴 수 있다.
[목을 가다듬음]
>> 네.
H 가격을 올리든지 아니면 그냥 법령
디행 가격이 확 빠지든지
>> 예. Hm 가격을 올리는 쪽으로 지금
바닥을 잡고 있는 거 같습니다.
>> 그러겠네요. 지금 이렇게 재고가 없다
보니까
뭐 가격이 확 빠질 것 같지 않고
그죠.
경고해지는 성벽 요렇게
자료에도 나오고 있지만 야 그러니까이
제고 추정치이 그래프만 보면 끝없이
펼쳐질 실크로드가 많네이
예상대로만 됩니다.
알겠습니다. 그리고 역대 최대 규모에
주조하는 기대라고 돼 있고 위에
김선우 연구원 자료에도 나와 있지만
그 3개년 주주 환영 규모가
100조원이라고 가정을 했는데 이게
매년 100조원이에요? 아니면 3개년
다 합쳐서 100조원이에요?
합쳐서라고 하고 있었는데요. 이제 한
내년 정도 되면 다 주는 정책을 다시
또 세워야 될 것 같습니다.
>> 그래요?
>> 보통 뭐 3년마다 이렇게 했었잖아요.
그게 내년이에요.
>> 예. 내년으로 제가 기억을 예.
>> 그리고 보니까 연말 추가 배당도
가능하다고 돼 있네.
15,000원.
지금은 이제 주가가 많이 올라가
가지고
>> 그래도
추가 배당 준다면 이거는 좋죠.
그죠? 안 받는 거보다 그렇죠.
>> 무조건 좋죠. 특별 배당 식으로 해서
했으면 좋겠습니다.
>> 그리고 요즘이 파운더리 쪽에서도 계속
좋은 소식이 계속 나오고 있습니다.
그죠?
>> 네.
>> 이번에는 엔스로픽에서
삼성한테 바운더리 맡기겠다 그죠?
>> 예.
>> 자, 그러면 어 예상 지금 삼성전자의
예상 주가는 지금 얼마로 나오고
있습니까?
>> -0.6%. 6% 정도 하락할 것으로
예상되고 있습니다.
>> 어 하이닉스도 -3%대
나오네요.
>> 네.
>> 그러면 충단금을 반영을 하기 전에는
그 김선훈 연구원 자료 제목처럼 충당
전에는 110조 가까이 나온 건데
[목을 가다듬음]
>> 왜 이렇게 시장의 평가가 좀 바죠?
어제 선반영
>> 어제 근데 3% 올라서 선반영
했다라고
>> 그는 좀 어려운 거 같고 좀
저번에 말씀드렸지만 약간 의심하는
사람들이 많이 좀 생기고 있는 느낌이
들거든요. 최근에 힘이 좀 딸리는
느낌이 많이 들었죠. 메타 이슈
이후에 확실히 좀
예전에 뭐 10명 중에 여덟 명이
빠지면서 하였다면 이제 그 숫자가
조금 내려가는 느낌.
저 그리고 아까 보니까
반대체 소부장도 어제 왜 그렇게 많이
빠졌어?
어 뭐 특별한 이슈는 없었고요. 근데
뭐 그냥 굳이 따지자면은
밸류에이션이 좀 많이 높긴 했었죠.
과거 사이클 대비로. 뭐 물론
사이클이 다르긴 하지만 아직 실적 안
나오는 종목들조차도 다 많이 올라가
있는 상황 속에서
받쳐 줄 수급이 없다 보니 일단 좀
밀리던게 아닌가라는 생각도 좀 들고
또 개인 투자자분들이
삼성 하이닉스도
빠지고 소부장도 빠지면 소부장 팔고
전자닉스를 또 살려는 수요도 있지
않을까 어차피 다 빠졌는데 생각 또
좀 들었습니다. 음.
근데 아까 반도체 제고 사이클이나 뭐
이런 거를 보면 일단 크게 지금 돈을
벌고 있고 뭐 막대한 투자가
이루어지고진다고 그러고 실제 중국
창신 메모리나 양리도 공격적으로
투자할 거고 그렇게 보면 밸류이션이
비싸지만 않으면 소부장은
>> 그렇게 빠지면 그죠
>> 하면 될 거 같은데. 야, 근데이
아까 소부장 종목들이나 뭐 소부장뿐만
아니라 그 삼성전자 하이닉스 두
배짜리 레버리지 때문에 변동성이
반도체가 심해졌다 이러는데 두 배짜리
레버리지가
없는데도
일반 종목들도 다 변동성이 엄청
심해졌네.
>> 예.
>> 참
파도타기 잘해야 되겠다. 그죠?
어떻게 해야 돼요? 그냥 파도타기를
잘해야 돼? 아니면 그냥 가만히
있어요.
저도 요즘에 좀 생각이 많아져 가지고
>> 이게 저는 이제 반도체를 이제 홀드
또는 좋다라고 보는데 시장에서는이
주가 흐름이나 이런 걸 보면 그게
아니라고 계속 얘기를 하고 있는 거
같아 가지고음
어느 정도 좀 수긍하면서 이전에는 뭐
너무나 오버헤이트였다면 그 부분을
내려가는 작업이 필요한 상황이다라고
생각을 하는데 그러면 그 내린
비중으로 딴 걸 사야 되잖아요.
음.
>> 딴 걸 산다고 해서 이게 크게
유미하게 다가올지에 대한 그것도 좀
고민이고 최근에 이제 시장에서
좋았던게 뭐 백화점이나
엔터도 좀 살아나는 거 같고 뭐
조선도 오늘은 좀 많이 빠지긴 하지만
조선도 좀 살아났었고 방산도
살아났었는데 근데이 추세가 이어지지는
않더라고요. 잘음
>> 그런 부분이 되게 요즘 시장 보면서
어려운 거 같습니다.음 음.
자, 알겠습니다.
오늘밤 미국 시장 어떻게 되는지 한번
미국 시장 예상을 해보고 국내장
예상해 보고 마치도록 하겠습니다.
자, 저 어제 미국장은 전부 오른다
예상했고 다 올랐잖아요.
>> 예, 다 올랐습니다. 예,
>> 그죠? 음.
오늘 7월 7일.
일단 7월 7일이니까 7원페어 잡고
지어가는 날인데
[웃음]
장프로 포카 칠 줄 알아요? 아,
네. 칠 줄 알 쳐요.
>> 잘 치는지 모르겠습니다. 칠줄.
>> 어, 잘 치는지 모르겠다면 한 판
쳐야 되고 [웃음]
잘 친다면 후해야 되고. 그렇죠.
어, 못친다. 못 쳐야지.
>> 예.이기는
>> 게임을 해야 됩니다.
자, 어떻게 됩니까? 오늘밤 미국
시장.
>> 수 상승.
>> 어,
>> 상승 예상
>> 상승. 네.
>> 상승 예상.
아예 장로가 나스닥하고
어, 추천가
저거 할까?
SP 500 할 것 같아. SP
>> 뭐 하고 싶어요?
>> 저 SP
>> SP
>> 그럼 장 장 장프로는 나스닥
>> 나스닥은 상승
>> SP 500
>> SMP는 쉬어갈 거 같습니다.
>> 살짝 쉰다. 오늘 마이너스
>> 네
>> 나스닥은 어떻게 될 거 같아요?
김프로
>> 나스닥도
>> 나스닥도 좀 쉴 것 같어.
>> 쉴 거 같다.
>> 그럼 두루서 만 원씩 걸어. [웃음]
>> 어 엇갈릴 때 엇갈릴 때는 그냥 만
원씩 걸고 가면 돼.
자 필반은 어떻게 됩니까?음
음.
[콧방귀]
아, 어려운데요. 음. 음, 일단은이
삼성전자 실적 이후에 뭐가 좀 어
그 모멘텀이 될 만한 뭐 소재들이나
이런 것들이 나와야 되는데
다음 주에 이제 그 CPI를
기다리면서 약간 좀 관망세가 이어지지
않을까라는 생각이 듭니다. 그래서 어
저는 필반도 쉴 것 같습니다.
>> 어 오늘 필반 쉰다고요?
>> 예. 어
그러니까 우리 최부 사장님의 뭐 항상
무조건 고하는 스타일은 아니다라는 거
>> 어렵습니다. [웃음]
>> 어렵습니다.
>> 예.
>> 오케이. 일반도 살짝 실수는 있다.
>> 네.
>> 그다음에 국내 시장 어떻게
시작했습니까?
>> 네.가
지금 아직 집회가 안 됐는데요. 네.
이제 집배됐는데 -1.64%로
64%로 어 하락해서 출발했고요. 어
현재도 똑같은 지수대입니다.
>> 어 7,919로 시작했네요.
>> 네
>> 그다음에 코스닥은 어떻게 됩니까?네
>> 코스닥 -0.39%
하락해서 출발했고 현재
-0.45%입니다.
>> 어차피 코스닥이 많이 빠졌습니다. 그
>> 네
>> 코스피 다시 한번 보여줘. 저봐요.
>> 네.
>> -1.64로
시작을 했고
삼성전자 하이닉스 어떻게 되고
있습니까?
>> 네. 삼성전자 -2.5% 하락하고
있고요. 하이닉스는 -0.1% 정도
하락하고 있습니다.
>> 음. 아까 뭐 -2% 정도로 예상
주가는 나오더니 그건 아니었다.
그죠?
>> 네.
그러니까 -2%로
굳이 그렇게 시작을 해야 되나 싶긴
했었는데
>> 외국인은 지금 어떻습니까?
>> 외국인 1,500억 사고 있습니다.
>> 1,500억?
>> 네.
>> 어,
한 5분 뒤에 다시 한번 보겠습니다.
네네.
>> 자, 오늘 코스닥
어, 어제 기분 나쁘게 뭐 빠졌어요.
그죠? 굉장히 기분 나쁘게 빠졌는데
왕부장이 어제 음봉 난다고
했었습니다.
>> 오늘도 음봉이죠.
>> 네. 맞습니다.
코스피는 어제 양복 예사.
>> 네.
>> 그래서 어제 어떻게 됐었죠? 어제
음봉 맞았습니다.
어제 뭐 장 중에 3%까지 시장이
거의 올라갔었다가
>> 어 그러게
>> -3% 갔다가 맞아요.
>> 약법 정도로
>> 끝나는 느낌이었는데
>> 어제 12시쯤이었나? 장중
된동선이거죠.
>> 굉장히 심했습니다. 갑자기 꺾이면서
>> 어제 장중에 뭐 그런 뭐 이슈가
있었어. 아 뭐 악재나 이런 것도
없었고 뭐 호재도 없었고 한데
좀 변동성이 확대가 되는 거
같습니다.
오늘은 어
전자가 4% 빠지고 있긴 한데
>> 4%까지
>> 뭐가 더 밀리네요.
그리고 뭐 그 잠수함 사업도 밀렸다
보니 조선이랑 방산 이렇게 아 막
5% 10% 이렇게 밀려서
>> 음
>> 그래도 오늘은 양봉 나지 않을까
싶습니다.
>> 어 그래도 오늘 양보
>> 아
[웃음]
>> 성구에 사실 무원의 압박이 있었거든.
>> 뭐라고? 오늘 장대 풀량봉을 외쳐야
된다.
>> 아는
>> 풀양봉 그거는 기대시 우리가 강연히
맨날 그런 걸 기대 하긴 해야 되는데
>> 근데 뭐
제 그러면 의견으로 가겠습니다.
오늘은
음봉이 왔습니다. 오늘 음봉이
>> 오늘 나중에 그 오과장에 옷나 차트
분석 한번 해 봐 봐.
[목을 가다듬음]
>> 근데 지금 보니까 104에 지금 고점
대비 16.4
9,385에서
또 16% 이래 빠졌는데
보니까 어제도 5개월 2평선을 강하게
이제 뚫었다 싶었는데 확 다시
밀렸다가 종가가 5개월 2평을
회복하지는 못하고 끝났었네요. 보니까
8,113이
어제 5일 아 5일 2평
그리고 오늘 또 시초가가 5일 2평선
밑에서 시작.
>> 네.
평이 좀 밀려서 내려와서
7,989까지 지금 떨어져 있는데
최초가가 그것보다 낮게 시작을 해
가지고이
512평을
약간 아직까지 512평이
강한 정확선으로
작용하는 모습이고 주봉으로도 봤더니
주봉이 지난주에 밑꼬리 쭉 달고 어
회복을 하긴 했었지만 지만 결국 5주
2평 8,367
밑에서 끝나는 그런 모습이 나오고 딱
이번 주에도 8,304가
5주 2평인데 어 요까지 딱 갔다가
거기서 막고 떨어졌네 보니까. 음.
>> 사실 그 어제 굉장히 특이했던 게
>> 외국인들이 콜옵션 이번 주 목요일이
옵션이
>> 어 그러네.
>> 근데 외국인들 [목을 가다듬음]
콜옵션을 2차라고 덮어.
>> 샀다고?
>> 네.
>> 어
>> 그 기존에 외국인의 옵션 포지션은
>> 우하향으로
했었는데
>> 그 변동성 크게
>> 포지션을 바꿔 놨고
>> 2,억을 어제 어제 아루에
>> 네.
굉장히 특이했습니다.
굉장히 많이 매수를 했고 포지션도 다
돌려 놨습니다.
>> 어 포지션도 어 그래요.
>> 그러니까 이번 주 목요일이 옵션
만기다. 그죠?
>> 네.
>> 자 외국인 동량이 아니 전자가 저렇게
매도 나오면 외국인이 때린 거
같은데.
외국인 소폭 팔고 있습니다. 150억
정도 매도가 나오고 있고요. 외국인
전체 시장에서는 지금 보합이
>> 네. 거의 보함입니다.
>> 어 그러면 전자를 누가 팔고 있는
거예요?
>> 기관인거.
>> 기관.
>> 네. 기관 또는 개인이지 않을까요?
>> 보통 개인 투자자가 이렇게
마이너스에서 팔지는 않는데.
외국인은 보니까 지금 삼성전자 이번
6월 25일 이후로 뭐 계속 팔기만
팔았는데
>> 그전에도 뭐 그랬죠.
>> 그러니까 지난주 금요일자로
그 기관이 삼성전자 매수가 좀 세게
들어왔거든요. 근데 1조 4천억
정도가 매수가 들어왔었거든요.
>> 네.
>> 그래서 아마 실적 발표 기대감 때문에
들어온 자금이지 않을까라고
생각하고요.
>> 예. 그 실적 발표가 잘 나오든 못
나오든 또 어느 정도 매도하는 해서
나가는 자금이 있지 않을까라고
생각합니다.
>> 음.
>> 아직까지 본 실적 발표가 좀 남아
있긴 한데 일단
실적 발표대 일단 때리고 보는 수요가
좀 있긴 하니까.
>> 네.
>> 코스닥은 지금 플러스로 돌아서는
모습이네.
>> 네.
스닥 지금 바이오 쪽이 상승세가 좀
나오고 있습니다.
>> 바이오 쪽이 강해요?
>> 네. 바이오 쪽이 강하고요. 뭐
DND 파마텍 한 12% 올라가고
ETF도 한 3%네
올라가고 웬만한
코스닥 종목들은 다 올라가는 거
같습니다. 아무래도 반도체가 좀
쉬어가다 보면 그 자금들이 다른
쪽으로 이제 순간매가 도는 거
같습니다. 음.
>> 한화 엔진 아까 NXD 장에서 뭐
거래 안 된다라고 댓글 창에서 보 거
같은데 하나 엔진은 한번 시초가가
얼마에 시작했어요?네
>> 하나 엔진 시초가가 44,500원에
>> 어 시작해 -15.88로 시작했다가
마이너스 지금 6%까지 쭉 올라왔네.
>> 네.
>> 어 차트 한번 한번 네
>> 볼까요?
하나엔진이 그동안에 한 고점 대비
거의 40% 빠져 있지 않았는데
반도났습니다.
오늘 오히려
점수 사업에 탈락했지만 아침 시초가가
거의 바닥이고 지금 양봉 나오고 있네
보니까 그니까 저 정도 가격이만
사야 됐다라고 이제 펀더멘탈 분석하는
사람들 입장에서는 오히려 뭐 아유
그거 뭐 탈락했다 해도 전체적으로
계속 좋을 건데 뭐 이런 느낌으로
사나 봐요. 그렇죠.
그거는 우리
승부 매니저한테 물어봐야지.
>> 사실 하나 오션에 들어 잠수함에
들어가는
엔진 같은 경우에는 하나의 엔진이
만드는게 아니라 그 STX 엔진이
만든
>> 아
>> 왜냐면 그 고속 엔진이기 때문에
굉장히 빨리 돌아가는 엔진이어서 하나
엔진이랑 전혀 연관이 없어서
>> 전혀 연관이 없는 거예요.
>> 네. 그래서 하나 오션이 오를 때도
하나 인체는 그렇게 별 반응이
없었거든.
>> 근데 사실 지금 ETF 쪽으로 매도가
나가오고 있다 보니까
>> 오히려 이럴 때는 굉장히 좋은 기회인
거 같습니다.
>> 어.
>> 그 밸루에이션도 사실 하나 인진
15배 정도. 그리고 현대말에는인지는
거의 10배가 깨지려고 하는 수준이
있더.
>> 네. 내년까지 실적 성장은 단부된
상황에서 이번 분기도 서프라이즈가 날
걸로 보여지는데 주가만 빠지고 있는
상황이기 때문에
>> 어 밸류 관점에서 굉장히
>> 매력이 있는 거 같습니다.
>> 음.
자, 그래서 고과장은
>> 저 음봉입니다.
>> 음봉한단
말이죠.
아니 왕박사 그 뭐 시스템적으로
말고
>> 네
>> 그냥 펀더멘탈이나 이렇게 그냥 보면
코스닥 이제 사야 되는 거 아니에요?
>> 시스템적으로 말고
>> 이거이 반도체대이 증종 섹터는 다
외고되었어요.
>> 외국이 되고 있다고.
>> 네. 왜 좋을 계속 내려가고
있습니다. 이거는 전세 뭐시 아니고
글로벌 다 트렌드가 이렇게 되고
있어요.
>> 아 글로벌 맞아요. 미국도 가고
중국도 가고
>> 우량주들이 [목을 가다듬음] 다 물을
한 단계로 계속 내려가고 있어요.
>> 그래서이 추제조 나와야 하는데 추제가
없으니까
>> 그래서 되게 애매해요.
>> 여기서는 뭐가 저핑가 되는데
>> 매수
추천 되게 어렵다고 생각해요.
매수네
>> 추천 아니면
>> 추천하기가 어렵다.
>> 아 난 매수 추천해도 됩니다. 이런
건 줄 알았더니
>> 아 뭐 개인적으로 그렇게 생각하고
있어요.
>> 개인적으로
>> 근데 왜냐면 저도 많이 투 당했어요.
이거 저핑과 저핑한데 또 또
싸졌어요.
뭐 15배에서 열배까지 나
>> 싸다고 생각해서 쌌는데 뭐 계속 더
빠지니까
>> 맞아요. 하는 사람이 계속 나오고
있고 예
좀 어렵다고 생각합니다.
>> 음도
뭐 말씀드렸지만
이게 가상화폐도 그렇고 전반적으로
지금 금값 은값도 뭐 다 빠지고
있거든. 요게 계절성이다는 거죠.
계절성. 제가 어 대통령 미국 대통령
4년차를
어 1년차 상반기 하반기 2년차
상반기 하반기 예 총 여덟 개로
나눠봤을 때 그러 보니까 우리나라 한
방에 보면 사상의양
>> 그걸 또 더 나눠서 나눠 가지고 지금
팔체질
>> 팔체질 들어가서 아 들어보긴 하는 거
같습니다. 예.
>> 그렇게 더 세 분해해 가지고 치료를
지금 한 방에 하고 있는데 그러니까
미국 대통령 4년차를 여덟개로
나눠봤을 때 따요. 789 789가
원래 그래요. 원래 그래서 아씨 왜
이래? 뭐 이렇게 좀 어 굉장히
좌개감이 되는 그런 차 좀 약간 밸류
투자하시는 분들이 입장에서는
자괴감이 되나 그런 장일 건데
그 밸류에 대한 확신이 있으면요
789 하여튼 요때
요때만 좀 견디시면 돼요. 때 계속
어제 이대우 기자의 그 와이스트
가서도 그 얘기 계속 말씀드렸는데
밸류다. 내가 확실하게 쌓 싸게
샀다라고 확신하는 분들은
좀 견디시고
저는 오히려이 정도 가격이면 또
물타게 해도 된다. 그래서 뭐 저는
그렇게 얘기해요. 근데
저희처럼 뭐 또 고객 자금을 운용하고
있는 입장에서는
그 너무 이렇게 소해되고 있는 이런
주식으로 포트폴리오를
그 채우 수가 없다 보니까 당장
모멘텀이 강한 실적 모멘텀이 강한
그런 주식 중심으로 일단 70% 이상
채워가야 되는
>> 그리고 다른 지금 기관들도
마찬가지입니다. 그렇게 하고 있는데
그러다 보니까이 소회된 주식이 좀 더
소회되고 계절적인 용량이 있다는
거죠. 그 해치 펀드 애들이
돌아오는게 올해 10월 말이면 또 돌
돌아옵니다. 예. 지금 7월이니까
7, 8, 9, 10개월 정도.
그래서 마음이 허하신 분들은 어제
제가 웜신박에다가
어 저희 어머니 작품전이 어제부터
시작이 됐으니까
>> 란 노예 있으니까 작품전 가서 구경도
하시고 좀 여름 더울 때 휴가도
가시고
오히려 계좌를 쳐다보면서 스트레스
받으시기보다는
오히려 약간 휴식 안식년
>> 예 주 주식도 좀 안식 식 투자 좀
하셔도 된다
말씀드리겠습니다.
>> 테란노 어딘지 알려주셔 가죠.
>> 테란노 DB 금융센터.
>> 아 DB 27장입니다.
>> 아 예 알겠습니다.
>> 입장 없었습니다. [웃음] 27
>> 저희 어머니가 계실 겁니다.
[목을 가다듬음]
박정호 어머니는 어떤 분이신가?
[웃음]
하시면 가서
>> 예.
>> 어머니도 만나뵙고
>> 그러시면 될 거 같죠. 예, 체슬리
모닝 브리퍼 오늘 7월 7일 순서는
여기까지 하겠습니다. 변동성
시환장에서
우리와 함께 슬기롭고 행복한 투자
하시기 바라겠습니다. 고맙습니다.
감사합니다.
[목을 가다듬음]